So, ich bin am Start Leute, hat ein bisschen länger gedauert, fast elf Kilometer ge- naja, na, abgerundet eher zehn
Kilometer ge-
geflitzt und ich bin erst um 8 Uhr
30 oder so losgelaufen, dementsprechend war ich erst 9 Uhr 35 oder sowas wieder daheim, also war
Na gut, ich meine, irgendwann muss ich auch mal ausschlafen, ja
Und ausschlafen heißt bei manchen ja bis 12 Uhr pennen, bei mir heißt ausschlafen bis 8
Oder nicht schon mal bis 8, bis 7.50 Uhr oder so ist bei mir ausschlafen
Ich meine, ihr müsst euch nicht wundern, warum ich immer boomer müde, boomer Bett um 22 Uhr oder 23 Uhr bin
Ich stehe halt sonst 7.30 Uhr oder so, 7 Uhr bis 7.30 Uhr normalerweise auf und sonntags halt auch mal 7.45 Uhr
Aber ihr wisst ja, im Alter braucht man eh weniger Schlaf
Nicht so wild
Mein Handy macht komische Geräusche
So
Also, Chat hier, ich muss gerade meinen Vorschau-Rechner noch anmachen, ich sehe gar nichts, außer hier den Chat im Fullscreen
Was macht eigentlich, gerade wo ich das Emote sehe, mich interessiert ja so Promi-Zeug und so überhaupt nicht, aber was macht
Eigentlich, was macht eigentlich der Wendler?
Nicht, dass es mich wirklich großartig interessieren würde, aber jetzt wo ich das Emote gerade sehe
Was, was treibt der eigentlich so? Ne, der ist nicht deadgill, der macht komische Sachen und
War der nicht bei Xavier Naidoo, was
Keine Ahnung, Flat Earth und alles unterirdische Bunker, wo Kinder entführt werden und hast du nicht, die erzählen doch den
Weird-Champigsten Kram, war der da nicht auch dabei irgendwie?
Vorschau-Rechner anmachen
Nice, gut
Ich muss mal kurz in meine Abyschnis
Mount Everest-Mails gucken, ob da irgendwas wichtiges dabei ist, was ich übersehen habe
Key-Shops
China-Chinesen-Hardware, Key-Shops, Zeug, von dem ich noch nie was gehört habe
Ey, gar nicht so übel
Und
World of Warships, Alter, wie oft wollen die noch schreiben? So
So
Gleich da ist vorbei, ich war gleich da, also ich bin, ich bin gleich da
Wenn wir gerade dabei sind, ich mache mal die VM an und mache mal Package-Updates
Arch, by the way, muss immer up-to-date sein
Massive
Bleeding Edge, 5-Hit
Updated
Top-aktuell, blazingly-fast
Software
Ich will es gar nicht so genau wissen
Um nicht zu sagen, es ist mir
Ups, irgendwie hat das mein
Cursor nicht richtig gecaptured
Updates, Shader, ich, Leute, die updaten immer Sachen
Ich weiß nicht mal, was es ist, warum ich das überlege, was ist Shader C?
Collection of Tools, Libraries and Tests for Shader Compilation, okay, warum habe ich das installiert, für was? Kann ich das
Deinstallieren und wenn, nein, kann nicht, weil
Lib Placebo, war ja das, okay, was ist Lib Placebo?
Reusable, GPU Accelerated Video Dings, okay
Und warum brauche ich das? Das brauche ich, weil, ah, VLC
Aha
VLC braucht es, ja, okay, dann, dann, dann lassen wir es installiert, VLC ist wichtig
Chatge, was meint ihr, bevor wir anfangen, uns Zeug anzugucken, meint ihr, ich packe das bis Ende des Jahres
Unter, unter einer Stunde, zehn Kilometer
Ich meine, ich habe noch ein bisschen Energie, so ist das nicht, also ich bin den letzten Kilometer heute mit fünfzehn gerannt
Da mein, da muss ich ganz schön außer Puste, aber trotzdem, ja
Das heißt, ich denke, es ist theoretisch möglich, noch ein bisschen schneller zu rennen
Und ich habe ja noch einen Monat Zeit, eineinhalb Monate Zeit, bis Ende des Jahres
Meint ihr, ich kriege das, ich kann das, kann das auf die Reihe kriegen, ich kann das packen
Also eine Stunde für zehn Kilometer bis Ende des Jahres
Also, das wird, das wird auf jeden Fall knapp
Das wird auf jeden Fall knapp, oh, ich muss mich, Chatge, Moment
Wollen wir mal gucken, ob ich unter 90 Kilo habe, Moment
Das muss ich kurz, das muss ich kurz ausprobieren
Ich muss mal kurz rüber, mich schnell wiegen, Zack, ich wiege mich mal schnell
Gucken, ob ich, das, das muss ich jetzt mal ausprobieren
Chat, es ist soweit, ich muss ein Foto machen, ich hab's, ich hab's geschafft
So
Die Waage hat mich massive gebatet
Ich bin gerade rübergegangen, habe mich draufgestellt
Da hatte ich noch Socken an und die Underhose, ja
Da hatte ich glatt 90 Kilo auf meiner Waage
Habe ich mir gedacht, okay
Du, du gehst jetzt rüber, holst das Handy, zum Waage fotografieren
Habe ich die Socken und die Underhose ausgezogen, habe mich wieder auf die Waage gestellt
90,2
Wie kann ich denn, bitteschön, ohne Underhose
Und Socken auf einmal mehr wiegen als vorher
Ich glaube, die Waage ist nicht so hundertprozentig accurate
Es ist halt
Das Händen, nee, nee, nee, das Händen
Ich bin ja nicht blöd, das Handy habe ich später in die Hand genommen
Nein, nein, nein, nicht das Handy
Ich stelle es nicht drauf und danach, wenn die gemessen hat, wird es fotografiert
Aber die hat mich massive, massive gebatet
Ich habe eine
Xiaomi Mi Scale 2
Nicht Home Assistant
So ein Ding und die ist schon halbwegs genau
Aber anscheinend
Schwankt es etwas, ja
Ja, das ist ja doof
Na gut
Dann
Dann halt nicht
Also
Soll mir recht sein, ja, dann
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall nicht mehr viel bis unter 90 Kilo
Kam der BF, was für, achso
Battlefield, es ist ja nicht Battlefield, es ist Black Friday
Nee, ich weiß auch ehrlich gesagt gar nicht, was ich da shoppen soll
Da ist doch eh immer der gleiche Müll
Tausend schwachsinnige Sachen, die keiner braucht
Amazon eigene Geräte, die sind immer ganz gut, wenn man denn welche braucht, aber ich brauche auch nicht das hundertste Fire Tablet
Und ansonsten ab und zu mal eine SSD oder sowas kann man da ganz gut abgreifen
Oh nee, nee, nee, ich habe
Leute, ich habe so keinen Bock auf MB3
Ich finde ja schon komplett kreativ, bankrott, alles seit dem 2019er Reboot von Modern Warfare
Das war aber wenigstens auch ganz gut gemacht, du hast gemerkt, dass da Leute dran gearbeitet haben, die irgendwie was
Ja, noch versucht haben, was auf die Reihe zu kriegen, ich finde bei MB2 hat man das schon deutlich weniger gemerkt
Und MB3 ist ja nun wirklich voll für den Arsch
Ich werde es nicht kaufen, ich werde es nicht spielen, ich werde es nicht streamen, ich werde meine Meinung nicht zu sagen
Also, das sag ich jetzt, kann sich nächste Woche schon wieder ändern, ihr kennt mich
Und nachdem mich Warzone auch nicht so großartig interessiert
Eigentlich kein Bock, überhaupt kein Bock auf MB3
Ich habe aber ein bisschen das ganze mitverfolgt und MB3 kommt allgemein auch genauso beschissen an, wie ich es mir vorgestellt habe
Ist das noch ein Röhrenfernseher?
Moment, der macht Videos wieder?
Das ist der, der noch die MB2
Ja, der die MB2 Nuke-Videos immer gebracht hat, gell?
Nuke-Challenge, Nuke-Challenge und so, da haben wir, ja
Aber ich habe jetzt, es interessiert mich nicht, es interessiert mich so wenig, dass ich mir, obwohl ich die Videos von ihm gerne geguckt habe
Dass ich nicht mal das Video dazu angucken will, gar kein Bock
Juckt mich überhaupt nicht
Da sind wir lieber Blazingly Fast, Written in Rust
Und dann haben wir hier noch ein Video von Warzone, ich glaube, das ist auch ein Video von Warzone
Blazingly Fast, Written in Rust
Das hat, Chatge, ich muss ja mal sagen, der Stream gestern hat echt Bock gemacht, ja
Auch wenn ich nichts gecheckt habe am Ende mehr
Aber man hat echt was gelernt
Ah ja, und ich habe unter anderem gelernt, ich werde Rust wahrscheinlich nicht für irgendwelche Daily-Projekte nehmen, wo es schnell gehen muss
Weil wenn eine Sache nicht ist, also wenn eine Sache Rust nicht ist, dann ist es schnell zu schreiben
Es ist vielleicht schnell, wenn es geschrieben ist und ausgeführt wird
Aber die Software zu erstellen ist Rust absolut das Gegenteil von Blazingly Fast
Ja, die ganzen krassen Krustentiere sagen jetzt natürlich wieder, Max, das liegt nur an dir, das kann schon sein, ja
Irgendwo liegt es natürlich immer an dem, der es programmiert
Aber wenn man das mal vergleicht, wie super weird-champig das alles aussieht
1000 Awaits, Unwrap, Get, Read Only, Unwrap, Unwrap, Await
Ne, da kriegst du Anfälle
So, die VM hat neu gestartet
Wir brauchen die VM jetzt gar nicht, ich lasse aber trotzdem mal an, es schadet auf jeden Fall nichts
Moin Darkseid, so dann lasst uns doch mal gucken
Was trendet denn
Auf Shithub die Woche
Schreckt mich nicht so
Was ist das? Hetzner for Gamers, was haben die denn da am Start?
Kannst du da als Minecraft-Server uns heucheln?
With our servers we have full control over your gaming environment
Ah ja, gut, mein
Ich gehe mal davon aus
Es ist komisch, dass die, dass die jetzt den
Also, was ich jetzt schon erlebt habe, ist der umgedrehte Fall, dass irgendein Game-Server-Hoster
Irgendwann auch mehr anbietet
Also so Nitrado oder sowas, falls überhaupt noch jemand benutzt
Die haben ja erst mit Game-Server angefangen und kann es jetzt auch noch mehr mieten
Aber Hetzner macht es jetzt umgedreht oder
Ja, wobei das hat doch mit Game-Server nichts zu tun, so ein ganz normaler Server, du kannst wahrscheinlich, du kannst wahrscheinlich
einfach
Über das, über das Management-Panel da jetzt Minecraft draufhauen, ohne dass du dich mit Linux auskennen musst oder
Also ich meine, ich meine, was ist der Vorteil davon, so ein ganz, so ein nackiger, nackiger Server, oder?
Cloud-Pricing, das ist ein ganzer, das hat doch mit Gaming-Sachen nichts zu tun
Das ist ein nackiger Cloud-Server
Okay, Hetzner, Hetzner sponsert die
Irgendeine League of Legends-Ding, was mit ihren Servern ja
Gar nichts zu tun hat
Ja, guck mal, hä, okay, du kannst
Ja, du musst, du musst sogar User und so alles selbst adden
Hä, das verstehe ich, das hat doch mit Game-Server, also mit fertigen Game-Servern gar nichts zu tun, das sind stinknormale Cloud-Server
Wo du dann halt beispielsweise Minecraft drauf installierst, das kann ich schon seit Jahren damit machen, das ist doch überhaupt nichts Neues
Ich glaube, das ist einfach nur
Marketing-Versuch für alle, die noch nicht auf die Idee gekommen sind
Dass man ja auch sich einfach einen Minecraft-Server selbst installieren kann und nicht bei irgendeinem Minecraft-Server-Hoster
das machen muss
Das denen noch mal zu erklären, dass das auch geht, ja
Im Prinzip ist es genau das gleiche wie vorher
Das könnte natürlich auch sein, das ist auch eine gute Idee, aber ich finde das interessant, dass Hetzner jetzt so
Richtung, Richtung
Online-Promotion, Gaming und
Online-Marketing-Sachen geht, also ich weiß noch, als ich, als ich mit denen telefoniert habe
Boah, keine Ahnung, wann habe ich die erste Hetzner-Sache damals gemacht?
Da war das, da hatten die noch ganz wenig Erfahrung mit Online-Sachen, das hat gerade erst angefangen, aber die haben es richtig gemacht
Die haben es richtig gemacht
Du musst heutzutage in die Richtung gehen
Und
Auch die Sponsorings, die sie da haben beim Bauer teilweise oder bei
Gibt ja, gibt ja noch mehr, ich glaube das ist genau das Richtige für die, weil dort gucken technik-interessierte Leute
Die dann sagen, ach ja gut
Ich bräuchte mal einen Server, wo geht man hin? Ah ja, guck mal, wie wäre es mit Hetzner? Da ist einfach wichtig, dass man bekannt ist
So und das hier ist jetzt eher so eine Sache mit, man nimmt das, was man schon hat
Und erklärt halt den Leuten, ey, guck mal, auch wenn ihr da bisher noch nicht dran gedacht habt, ihr könnt auch so was nehmen und euch
Selbst Minecraft drauf installieren, obwohl das im Prinzip schon
Schon immer geht
Das gibt es garantiert schon, das gibt es garantiert schon
Minecraft-Installer und sowas und ich würde es auch nicht wundern, wenn die im Control-Panel bei Hetzner demnächst irgendwie so Standard-Gameserver anbieten würden
Das muss man nämlich sagen, das Web-Interface von Hetzner, also zumindest für Hetzner Cloud, ist echt gut
Das ist minimalistisch, das man muss ja auch mal ehrlich sagen, die Hetzner Cloud an sich von Features her können die jetzt ja nicht viel
Die haben 4Ms, die haben Storage und die haben
Loadbalancer, das war es im Endeffekt, also das ist ja, man würde ich sagen, das ist ja das absolute
Minimum, dass man sich irgendwie vielleicht Cloud nennen darf, aber das Zeug funktioniert ziemlich gut, was sie haben funktioniert ziemlich gut
Und es ist preislich super
Und das, was integriert ist, also das, was sie haben, ist auch super integriert in das Web-Interface und geht super schnell
Ich meine ernsthaft, wenn ihr mal bei Google Cloud rumklickt, dort 4Ms, Storage, sonst was, das fühlt sich alles so
Unglaublich laggy an im Browser und bei Hetzner flutscht das und ist blazingly fast. Ich weiß nicht, ob die written in Rust sind
Aber das fühlt sich schon deutlich angenehmer an
Aber natürlich ist es auch unfair, das zu vergleichen, weil wenn du dir anguckst, was du beispielsweise bei Google in der Cloud für Features hast
versus
Was du bei Hetzner hast, das ist halt, Hetzner hat halt so
Drei Prozent von dem, was Google hat
Dafür preislich deutlich attraktiver bei den Sachen als Google. Bei Google bezahlst du für eine fette VM
Durchaus mal 1000 Euro im Monat, bei Hetzner kostet das 300
Und bei Hetzner kriegst du auch richtig fette Hardware-Kisten mit 32 Kern Ryzen-CPU
64 oder 128 Gigram, 64 Terabyte NVMe-SSD für 500, 600 Euro im Monat
Und bei Google gibt es das schlicht und ergreifend gar nicht
Es ist nicht Sponsored-Stream
Ich müsste mit denen mal wieder
Irgendwas vereinbaren, ich hätte echt Bock, mal wieder irgendwas anzupreisen von Hetzner
Aber wir haben schon eine Weile nichts mehr gemacht, ich habe auch keine guten Ideen gehabt mehr
Und jetzt mit der neuen Arbeit und so habe ich ja eh weniger gestreamt, aber ich glaube, es wäre mal wieder an der Zeit
eine Runde Hetzner-Promotion zu machen
Ich meine, ich promote die ja indirekt oftmals auch, ohne dass ich dafür Geld kriege, einfach weil ich das Zeug nicht schlecht finde
Ja, das wäre natürlich nice
Das würde bestimmt viele überzeugen, die haben ja schon so ein paar One-Click-Installer für WordPress und so was
Warum nicht auch für Minecraft anbieten? Ich meine, ehrlich
Minecraft dürfte wahrscheinlich der Hauptantrieb für Gameserver heutzutage sein, weil in was mieten sich Leute denn heutzutage Server?
CS wie früher? Nö, CS-Server hat doch heute keiner mehr wirklich
Battlefield-Server gibt es nicht mehr, Cod-Server gibt es auch keine
Vielleicht Rust oder so was
Rust vielleicht, weiß nicht, ob das noch angesagt ist
GTA, ja, ja vielleicht
GTA, Rust und so was in der Richtung, aber hauptsächlich, das meiste vermutlich, würde ich jetzt einfach mal raten
Vielleicht auch der ein oder andere, aber die meisten Server, die so gemietet werden für Gaming heutzutage, so Community-Gaming mäßig
sind wahrscheinlich ernsthaft Minecraft-Server, würde ich jetzt mal raten
So, lass uns mal gucken, was auf Shithub trendet
Draw a UI
Was ist das?
Das ist ein neues Repo, das kenne ich noch gar nicht. Ja, es ist neu, alter
14 Tage altes Repo
Und einfach mal 10.000 Sterne, alter
Das ist ja fast so viel wie der Fiat Champ
Nicht ganz, aber fast
Was macht der Fiat Champ eigentlich mit Issues?
Ah, immer noch keine Fehler, sehr gut
Was ist das? Ja, das versuche ich gerade rauszubekommen
Man malt was und daraus erzeugt AI und TL-Draw
Dann HTML
Also man malt quasi in Paint was und das erzeugt dann das, was man in Paint gemalt hat, also in diesem Paint-Verschnitt
wird dann als HTML
generated
Zeige euch das hier
Kann man das groß machen vielleicht, so?
Okay, und da macht AI jetzt eine Webseite draus. Okay, nicht schlecht
Ich frage mich, inwieweit das in der Praxis wirklich brauchbar ist
Du kannst dir vielleicht Inspiration holen
Aber ich frage mich halt, wie maintainable das ist, was das da raushaut
Aber man muss super schnell, quick and dirty was auf die Reihe kriegen
Und kann ich richtig HTML
und CSS?
Ist das, glaube ich, gar nicht verkehrt
Auf jeden Fall coole Idee
Okay, man braucht einen Open AI-RP-Key
Was kein Ding ist, um es auszuprobieren, weil man kann ja das kostenlose Kontingent benutzen, aber coole Sache
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass die AI durchaus auch
Vue oder React-Apps
Generaten kann mittlerweile oder sogar Svelte-Apps
Aber eine coole Idee, das ist auf jeden Fall nice
Das ist, finde ich, ein gutes Beispiel, wo AI einem auch mal ein bisschen Arbeit abnehmen kann
und
sei es nur zu Inspirationszwecken
So, okay, AI, lassen wir bleiben, AI, AI
Monaspace
Okay, weitere, weitere, okay
Ich bin ja immer ganz
Interested, was neue Fonts angeht. Ich benutze seit Jahren Hack als Font, aber ich gucke mir auch immer gern mal
Okay
Alter
Font-Fachsprache, ja?
Each one has a distinctive voice
Wie kann ein... Ich meine, ich weiß, ich kann mir überdenken, was die mir sagen wollen, ja?
Die wollen sowas sagen wie, jedes hat so ein spezielles, ein spezielles Merkmal
aber
Das ist ja fast wie wenn Weinkenner erzählen, oh, es ist so, fragt mich nicht, wie Weinkenner das
Erdig im Abgang, sowas, ja
So, oder die Whisky-Leute, man merkt das Eichenfass auf der Zunge oder sowas
Der Font
Also, bei mir ist es der Font, kann man sich sicherlich drüber streiten
Wobei ich die Varianten hier eigentlich ganz hübsch finde
Oh, ne
Ich mag das nicht
Jemand von euch Liggers, ich kann das Wort nicht aussprechen
Fan
Also, das ist, hier sieht man das ganz gut, guck, mit, wie heißt das auf deutsch, Ligaturen oder so
Ligaturen, ernsthaft
Ligaturen
Ligatures
Mag das jemand von euch? Also, man sieht hier, guck mal, zum Beispiel, wenn man ein Font hat, hier sieht man es ganz gut, wenn man ein
Font hat, der Ligatures
unterstützt, normalerweise sieht das so aus, ja, dass man da sagt größer gleich
Und wenn man ein Font hat, der Ligaturen kann, dann macht er aus zwei Zeichen
Auch, wenn die, wenn die logisch gesehen immer noch zwei Zeichen sind im Code, macht er aber in eurem Editor da draus so ein
eher Quickmaps-Symbol
Ich mag das nicht
Ich weiß, da streiten sich die Geister dran, ob das jetzt gut oder nicht gut ist
Das ist scheiße, das ist genial, okay, Chat, wo wir gerade dabei sind, da streiten sich die Geister dran, ja, die sind genial, das ist scheiße
Wollen wir voten? Okay, wir voten, ich war mal ein Vote
Vote
Moment, nee, nee, Paul
Ligatures
Ja oder nein?
Fragezeichen, ja, nein
Machen wir was anderes
Genial
Mist
Ab und zu
Additional Votes per Kekse
Ja, die Leute sollen mal ein bisschen Kekse ausgeben, können wir da
Also, bin ich mal gespannt, was da rauskommt
Eine Minute, Mist
Ich tendiere auch zu Mist
Also die meisten Leute denken
auch, es ist Mist
65% denken, es ist Mist
22% denken, ab und zu kann man das mal verwenden
Und ein paar denken
ganz toll, super genial
Ja, so ungefähr
Was?
Nee, nee, nee, das da wird zu
Twitch
Benutzt auch
Ligaturen
Oder ist das FFZ
Nice, Alfred
Pog
Ja, ja, das stimmt schon
Es ging ja darum, ob man es mag oder nicht
Ich mag es nicht
Letztendlich ist der Source Code der gleiche, der rauskommt
Es macht doch heute kaum noch einen Unterschied
FFZ kann 7 TV Emotes
Nur ich glaube, Better Twitch TV verwendet kaum noch einer
Ja
Das hat dann auch mega Bock gemacht
Vor allem hat man mal was gelernt
Rüsttechnisch
Ich bin
geneigt, das mal auszuprobieren
Monaspace
Lasst mal kurz checken, ob es das hier
OTF Monaspace
Super Innovativ
Super Family
Nee, Moment
Lasst mich mal kurz Monaspace installieren
Ah, Moment
Die Frage ist, ob mit Monaspace
Mal kurz im Terminal ausprobieren
Wir testen das mal kurz
Im Terminal
Config Western
Pond
Fallback Hacked
Wie heißt denn dieser Kram
Jetzt überhaupt
FC List
Crap Monaspace
Alter, was
Alter, wie viele
WTF
Alter
Wie viele Monaspaces gibt es denn da
Bitteschön
Das hört ja gar nicht mehr auf
Okay, wir müssen das
Wir müssen das doch mal in einem anderen Editor mit grafischer Font-Auswahl machen
Gab es nicht bei Gnome
Auch so ein Font-Select
Monkaspace
Okay, hier können wir uns das angucken
Pond
Also das ist glaube ich sogar
Ist das JetBrains Mono oder Hack
Das müsste eigentlich Hack sein
Also dieses
Also manchmal
Ist das echt pp
Wtf
Normalerweise
Findet man das hier doch da drüber
Nee, es ist JetBrains Mono
Also normaler
Font, den ich verwende
Normaler Font
Erkennt man kaum Unterschied
Hatten die nicht mal einen
Apply-Knopf
Ach hier neben kann man sich ja die Vorschau angucken
So, Monaspace
Guck mal
Hack und JetBrains Mono
Ist gar nicht so viel Unterschied
Außer dass Hack ein bisschen mehr Spacing hat
Zwischen den
Zwischlinge
So und jetzt hier
Monaspace
Monaspace Argon
Okay
Krypton
Oh nee
Das sieht kacke aus hier drin
Das gefällt mir nicht
Guck mal, da hat sogar Ryder Probleme
Irgendwie das zu rendern, richtig
Nee, das gefällt mir nicht
Aber
Das geht noch irgendwie klar
Neon
Oh ja, das finde ich ganz gut, das gefällt mir noch besser als
Argon
Wobei kann man schon
Radon
Oh nee, das ist für Comic-Sans-Lovers
Xenon
Hm
Ich muss fast sagen, ich glaube Argon
Oder Neon
Also Neon
Oder Argon, gefällt mir da am besten
Ich tendiere zu Neon gerade
Wobei ich bei Argon
Das J
Mir besser gefällt
Na gut
Wir bleiben
Aber JetBrains
JetBrains Mono
Ach hier, na das muss man
Wahrscheinlich aktivieren erst
Hm
Wir sollen
Ligaturen mal testen
Vierer Code kenne ich
War nicht so meins
Guck mal, kann man hier sogar
Ist glaube ich
Ist das sogar eingebaut
Sieht sehr ähnlich aus
Auch
Also ich sehe da jetzt keine
Ligaturen enabled
Aber
Also JetBrains
Mono kann es auf jeden Fall
Was auch immer
Wisst ihr was, zack
Ich bleibe einfach bei dem Font, der hier eingestellt ist und gut ist
Cascadia Mono
Ich muss allgemein sagen
Ich finde die Microsoft-Schrift
Die Microsoft-Terminal-Schriften
Auch gar nicht übel
Nicht so, dass ich sie unbedingt verwenden möchte
Cross-Plattform, aber ab und zu
Ich bin dann immer angenehm überrascht
Obwohl Cascadia als auch
Lucida Console sind eigentlich
Sehr nice Schriftarten
Von Microsoft
Denkst du gotter
Docker läuft gut in einer Vm, klar
Warum nicht
Docker läuft perfekt in VMs
Um nicht zu sagen, ich verwende hier
Docker eigentlich nur in VMs
Warum sollte das nicht laufen, wunderbar
Läuft das
So, dann gucken wir mal weiter
Ich uninstalle
Das mal wieder
Ach komm, wir lassen es drauf
Bei uns läuft ein
Kubernetes-Cluster in einer Vm
Ja und, ist doch gut, ist doch okay
Selbst bei Google
Läuft, glauben die, Kubernetes-Cluster
In VMs
Bietet sich auch oftmals an
Einfach weil du dann auch die Node-Anzahl
Und alles sogar noch ein bisschen einfacher rauf und runter
Skalieren kannst, falls man das möchte
Ich finde es gar nicht so verwerflich
Kubernetes-Cluster in einer Vm laufen zu lassen
Sogar VMware
Bietet ja mittlerweile ein
Kubernetes-Interface
Für ihr Vm-Zeug an
Nennt sich Tanzu
Deine Meinung zu ESX
Ich habe wenig Erfahrung mit ESX
Ich benutze das seit Jahren
Im Enterprise-Business-Umfeld
Aber die Betonung liegt auf
Benutzt, nicht administriere
Oder großartig was mitmachen, ich benutze das
Das funktioniert eigentlich
Grundsolide
Selten
Probleme, die ich da mitbekomme
Es funzt, genau, es funzt
Ja, vm in vm
Sieht schon wieder anders aus, vm in vm
Kann schon echt Performance-Probleme geben
Nested-Virtualisierung
Aber nachdem Docker ja keine
Virtualisierung ist, ist das überhaupt kein Problem
Container ist eh
Das größte
Gebate-Wort
Es sind ja
Gibt es gar keine Container
Ja, funktioniert halt
Okay, was trendet
Sonst noch
Proxmox, ESX
Ich glaube, das hängt ganz von dem Anwendungsfall an
Wenn man daheim irgendwas haben will
Oder nicht viel Kohle hat
Die man vm, wobei ESX in der Basic-Variante
Glaube ich auch kostenlos ist
Wenn man nicht viel Kohle hat, die man vm
Hinterher schmeißen will, dann Proxmox
Und das ist Xen-Server
Habe ich ewig nicht mehr im Einsatz gesehen
Wobei, Xen, das ist die Citrix-Geschichte
Das ist die
Die Citrix
Sache
Citrix ist doch
Xen, oder?
Das sehe ich äußerst selten
So, was haben wir hier sonst noch
AI juckt mich nicht
AI, AI, AI
AI
Was, Obama-Web-UI
Ach ne, Obama-Web-UI
Obama-Web-UI
AI, AI
Tesla-Stelz
Bringt mir nix
AI, AI, AI
Rails-Trend
Jawoll, Leute
Ruby
On Rails trendet
Dass ich das noch erleben darf
Gab es da eine neue Version
Oder warum trendet das
Warum bearbeitest du die
URL ständig
Hi-IQ-Move
Okay, 7.12 kam raus
Ich muss ja sagen
Eigentlich ist Ruby
Meine Lieblingsprogrammier-Sprache
Das Ding ist nur
Mittlerweile kannst du es halt
Ich hab schon fast verlernt, wieder Ruby zu programmieren
Weil man Ruby halt heutzutage nicht mehr braucht
Und Rails auch
Auf nem ziemlich
Ich glaub, man kann nicht mal mehr sagen, absteigenden Ast ist
Rails
Hat gar kein Ast mehr
AI, AI
Was?
Die Namen von den Java-Skripten
Das ist gar kein Start
Achso, China-Chinesen-Proxy-Kram
Und AI
Top
Also diese Woche hat ja im Prinzip
Okay, ich glaube, dass sogar
Diese Woche relativ viel .NET-Zeug trendet
Weil es gab ja
Das .NET-Release
Und es gab jetzt diese
Microsoft-Konferenz, wo es jede Menge Talks
Zu .NET gab, da könnte einiges trenden
Okay, für alle, die Sachen
Highly over-engineeren wollen
Avalonia ist
Wirklich Pog
Wenn ich ja XAML mögen würde
Wäre das
Wahrscheinlich so mein Go-To-Cross-Platform-
UI-Framework
Und wenn ich mal Cross-Platform-UI machen muss
Vielleicht
Was ich möglicherweise eigentlich nie machen muss
Dann probiere ich es vielleicht echt nochmal mit Avalonia
Ist es denn
Written in Rust, blazingly fast
Ansonsten benutze ich es nicht
Nein, es ist written in Java-Skript
Was ist das überhaupt
Innovatives
Open-Source-Visualisierung-Tool
Transformiert
JSON, YAML, XML
CSV und mehr
Interactive Crafts
Okay, das könnte man tatsächlich gebrauchen
Wenn man es braucht
Also, ich glaube das ist so ein typisches Tool
Wenn man es mal braucht, ist man froh drüber
Dass man es
Hat
Das ist glaube ich ganz nice, um sich durch
Deeply nested JSON-Dinger
Durchzuklicken
Ja, ja
Es ist immer eine gute Gelegenheit in .NET
In C-Sharp einzusteigen
Wir müssen uns auch noch ein Video
Ansehen, was neu in C-Sharp ist
Mal gucken, da gibt es doch bestimmt
Eines bei, das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht jetzt an
Aber, ach guck mal hier ist wieder
Der Programming-Tier-List-Dude
Den haben wir doch das letzte
Moment, den haben wir doch das letzte Mal
Schon
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, was darunter
Pass auf, pass auf
Wir jibaden mal wieder
Die YouTube-Seite, okay
So, wir gucken am Ende, was rauskommt
Shorts, Keckel
Das ist ja die weird champigste Auswahl
An Programmiersprachen, um sie zu ranken
Überhaupt
Da fehlt ja gefühlt alles
Aber Hauptsache
JavaScript ist goat
Ist hier, okay kann man so sehen
Aber C++
Auf A-Tier setzen
Guck mal hier
47 hoch, 40, ist das jibade?
Ist das ein jibade-Video, um möglichst viele
Comments zu baten?
Das könnte man machen, das ist eigentlich
Absolutes Six-Head-Idee
Also das habe ich auf YouTube auch schon
gemerkt, wenn man viele Kommentare haben
will, muss man absichtlich was
Falsches erzählen und möglichst überzeugend
sagen, dass sich viele Leute korrigieren
wollen, so, aber Max
Bei 2 Minuten 30, das ist nicht
korrekt, was du da sagst
Das ist eine Verarschung, ne
Das ist, das ist, das ist
Ich glaube, ich glaube, der
Will uns jibaden, wirklich viel
Comments baten
What's new in C-Sharp?
Da gab es doch letztens erst
Nicht vor 5 Monaten
Auch nicht
Das hier, genau
Also das gucken wir nicht jetzt, Leute, aber
Genau, haben die eigentlich
Mehr als 720p, also haben sie es geschafft
1080p, okay
Ja
What's new in C-Sharp? Da bin ich mal gespannt, ob sie
Ob sie mir die neuen Features
Schmackhaft machen, weil ich bin ja
Ich bin ja schon der Meinung, die letzten paar
.Net-Versionen sind
Open-Source-Unternehmen-Umsetzung
Die IT ist es von seiner
Firma?
Die
Also, die müssen mich echt überzeugen
Ich fand, die letzten paar C-Sharp-Versionen
Haben sich erstens
Unfertige Sachen immer mal wieder eingeschlichen
Und
Was haut Nintendo raus? Ach so
Remake
Und ein paar Sachen
Sind auch unnötig kompliziert
Mittlerweile
Das ist doch nichts Neues, gibt es doch schon ewig
Automatisches Ausführen
Aber written in Rust, dann ist es gut
Blazingly fast
So
Was trendet denn in .Net? Lass uns mal schnell angucken
Also Avalonia hat es auf jeden Fall verdient
Für alle, die es
Übermäßig kompliziert machen wollen
Blazer
Ist auch so ein Ding
Also mich würde nicht
Wundern, wenn die MAUI demnächst einstellen
Das Microsoft hat ja
Einen guten Ruf, was
UI-Frameworks angeht
Blazer ist eine gute Idee, ich muss aber sagen
Außer initial, als es rausgekommen ist
Habe ich mich nie mehr mit Blazer
Beschäftigt, weil ich einfach bis jetzt
Nicht so den Riesen-Anwendungs
Nicht so den Riesen-Anwendungs-Kram
Für mich da drin sehe
Das Coolste, was es gibt
Für mich von Blazer ist Blazer
Kleinseitig, also .Net per WebAssembly
Aber das letzte Mal, als ich das geguckt habe
Musstest du da noch einen Riesen-Runtime
Von 8-9 MB runterladen
Bis es überhaupt losging
Das kannst du für so interne Business-Anwendungen
Sicherlich verwenden, aber für normale Webseiten
Eher nicht
ASP.NET, das hat es verdient
Meiner Meinung nach das beste
Web-Framework, das es gibt
Also Backend-Web-Framework
Das es gibt
Irgendjemand, der sich die Mühe gemacht hat
Oldschool WPF
Modern aussehen zu lassen
Maui
Ja, dass das überhaupt Sterne bekommt
Verstehe ich nicht
.Net Runtime, ja das hat es
OpenAI, ok, klar, dass das
Ach, das ist
SDK, ja, ok, ergibt Sinn
Blazer
AI
Plotinosi
Ach, das ist ein
Das ist dieser Windows-11-Deploter
Reverse-Proxy
Das ist das, was früher YARP
hieß, oder?
Ist das nicht früher YARP?
Doch, es heißt sogar immer noch so
Aber Hauptsache
Microsoft nennt es jetzt anders
Beispiel-Anwendungen
Irgendein Game
Ohne Screenshots
Ähnliche Bindings für
APN-Punkte
Simulator, ok, ja
Osu!
Endlich, Chat, wo sind
Wo sind die Weebs?
Also man kann in Osu natürlich auch
anderes Zeug machen
Aber
Ich habe den Eindruck, dass
99% der Osu-Spieler
Irgendwelche Anime-Musik
da drinnen abspielen
ZackHacks
Spoofy
MassiveHackerMan-Kram
Hatten wir das nicht gerade schon?
Ach nee, das ist die Backend-Seite
Azure SDK, ok
Und Blazer
GRPC
Counter-Strike
Sharp
Server-Plugins in C-Sharp
Damit, also ich hätte ja
mit allem gerechnet, aber nicht mit
sowas hier
Das
Damit hätte ich echt nicht gerechnet
Also
Du kannst ruhig noch ein paar posten, wenn es jemand
interessiert
Und wenn es jetzt nicht irgendwie 50
Stück sind, hau rein
Vielleicht ist auch irgendwas für mich dabei
So, dann
Wissen wir jetzt, was trendet
Nice, nice
Was ist das?
CLI
Taskrunner, defined by
Hä, wozu braucht man sowas?
Written in Rust, was sonst?
Das ist quasi ein
Markdown-Makefile sozusagen
Sehe ich das richtig?
Eigentlich eine coole Idee
Markdown-Makefile, warum nicht?
Garten-Kralle
Danke für den Sub
Excellent
Und Matrix HD
Auch resubscribed
Falls du noch da bist, sorry, hab ich nicht gesehen
Pog
Subscription
Das hört ja gar nicht mehr auf
Das brauchen wir noch, bitte
So, dann machen wir mal
ShitHub zu
YukiCat, danke für den Sub
Der Name
Ohne dir
Ohne dir zu nah treten zu wollen
Der Name klingt ein bisschen
Ein bisschen WeepsIn
mäßig
Alter, wie viel Zeug
Du starst prinzipiell nur Rust-Repos, oder?
Kannst du den CamChamp
demnächst auch starren
Also
Nope
Also Chat
Was meint ihr?
Krieg ich's hin bis Ende des Jahres?
10km unter einer Stunde oder nicht?
Ich tippe auf, ich krieg's nicht hin
Easy
Na easy wird, es ist nicht easy, Leute
Man denkt es ist easy
Es sind ja nur 4 Minuten 28 weniger
Aber das bedeutet
22 Sekunden pro Kilometer
Und das ist sehr viel anstrengender
Also 6 Minuten pro Kilometer
Ist sehr viel anstrengender als 6 Minuten 22
Alles Mindset
Ja, das Grinder
Grinder
Nee, Kreiselgrind
Grinder Mindset
Heute sind Opa an mir vorbei gerannt
Der war eine ganze Ecke schneller
Als ich und bestimmt irgendwie
Keine Ahnung, 70 oder so
Warum? Warum ist das grenzwertig?
Es ist halt anstrengend
Außerdem kommt das immer davon an
Was man für maximal
Herzfrequenz hat
Ja, das hab ich jetzt zum ersten Mal
Das hab ich
Das hab ich zum ersten Mal
Seit ich angefangen hab zu rennen überhaupt realisiert
Dass die
Doppelt so schnell wie ich rennen
Und das über 41, 42 Kilometer
Und das ist halt super krass
Die Dudes da
Und
Und was mir auch aufgefallen ist
Wie krass die Fahrradprofis sind
Wenn die da irgendwie mit 6,8
Watt
Pro Kilogramm den Berg hochflitzen
Und ich meine Probleme habe
45 Minuten 2 Watt
Pro Kilogramm zu bringen
Die sind leichter als ich, aber trotzdem
Das ist heftig
Ja, na klar
Aber trotzdem
Mega heftig
Die laufen ungefähr 20
Ungefähr 20 kmh
Bisschen schneller
Als 20 kmh laufen die
Im Marathon
Mal kurz was gucken
Ja
Guck mal, du musst 20 kmh laufen
Dass du 40 Kilometer in 2 Stunden packst
Die laufen
Etwas über 20 kmh
Das kenn ich, damit haben wir doch sogar schon
Was gemacht im Stream
Vor allem weil das Ding Kekona heißt
Ich glaube nicht, dass der
Dass der in irgendeiner Art und Weise
An Kekona
Gedacht hat
Machst du auch bei so Firmenläufen? Nö
Nächstes Jahr laufe ich beim Frankfurter Challenge
Laufen mit Leuten, das sind glaube ich nur 6 Kilometer
Aber eigentlich habe ich keinen Bock damit zu laufen
Weil er so spät ist
Mit GoPro
Ja
Hänge ich mir eine GoPro um und flitz los
Agil, Dankeschön für den Sub
So, dann gucken wir doch mal
Was es jetzt auf YouTube zu gucken gibt
Hä?
Ja, ja, Moment
Naja, also 6 kmh ist nicht so schnell
Okay, na dann
Ja, ich habe Open Sense eine Weile bei mir daheim verwendet
Aber jetzt nicht mehr
Weil ich das alles etwas entzerrt
Habe an Geräten
Ich hatte früher viel zu viel auf einer Kiste laufen
Also man kann sich streiten wo die Grenze ist
Zwischen quasi
Laufen, also sagen wir mal gehen
Laufen und
Rennen so, weil
Ich muss sagen
Oder sagen wir mal joggen, ja
Also laufen, joggen, rennen
Also ich muss sagen so die 6
6,30 pro Kilometer
Oder 6,22
Das ist, das ist
Auf jeden Fall noch joggen
Aber es ist so, es geht auf die Grenze
Beim Rennen zu
Also ich würde sagen so unter 6
Unter 6 oder sagen wir mal
Spätestens bei 5,30 ist das Rennen
Rust, genau
So, dann gucken wir mal was wir uns auf YouTube
Angucken können, was haben wir denn hier schönes
Copium Time
Was ist das denn
8 GB
Of RAM on M3
MacBook Pro
Das ist doch eindeutig Text to Speech
Oder?
Claims Apple
Ja Apple erzählt viel
Wenn der Tag lang ist
Apple, oh man die erzählen da viel
Shit wenn der Tag lang ist
Linux Disk richtig verkleinern
Verkleinern ist in der Tat schwieriger
Als erweitern
So kaputt ist E-Mail und sie
Wird trotzdem nicht sterben
Da gehe ich d'accord mit
Nie mehr
Arbeiten durch 4% Regeln
Alles klar
Das hat auch immer mehr
Comedy Corporal Vibes
Coding in C until I go
Completely insane
Ok, im Prinzip
Ist er insane nach einer Minute
Let's get started on that homework
Assignment, using floating point numbers
Oh Gott was soll ich ausmachen
Prove that 0.1
Plus 0.2 equals 0.3
Bonus points
If you can use 17 digits of floating point
Oh oh oh oh
Ich weiß worauf es rausläuft
After 3
Failed attempts we will
Power down your computer
Bro this one is so easy
So include standard.h to get that library in there
Into main
Get your argc and your argv
Type in real fast this time
We'll do float a equals 0.1
Float genauigkeit
0.2
Printf
Float type
Print a plus b
Return 0
Gcc
Output floats
From homework.c
Boom
Let's get those bonus points
0.17
Gcc again
Easy
Woah
Python help me out here
I don't
I don't understand
What is going on
JavaScript please
What
Ja float genauigkeit
Das ist immer so ein Ding
Angular
MonkaS
Will er sich das wirklich antun
Angular hör mal bloß auf
Was verdient ein Postbot
Was haben wir
So kaputt ist
E-Mail
Komm das gucken wir an
Die machen doch immer gute Witz
Also ich gehe mit dem Überschrift
Vollkommen mit
E-Mail ist seit Jahrzehnten gefühlt kaputt
Aber E-Mail
Wird weiterhin
Eines der wichtigsten Kommunikationskanäle bleiben
Ich schreibe mir E-Mail
Das machen wir
Ja FWR
Forward
Re
AWFW
Und dann zwischendrin
Weitergeleitet
Der Verteilerkreis
Bei allen Antworten
Auf einmal 60 Leute
Wöchentlich als
CT3003 Newsletter
Und ist aus dem Arbeitsalltag
Von fast allen Menschen
Nicht wegzudenken
Und bei Betreffzeilen gilt
Je mehr
E-Mail
Geht dann
Richtig gut
Wenn sie nicht mehr in die Vorschau
Auf das Smartphone
Die E-Mails
Kürzen das ja viel
E-Mail
Findet
Natürlich
Gehören E-Mails
Auch privat
Absolut zum Alltag
Kino Karte bestellt
Du kannst entweder deinen eigenen Mail-Server betreiben...
Ah, gute alte Sandkiste.
Die kenne ich ehrlich gesagt
nur vom Sehen noch.
Und gemacht habe ich
damit nie was.
Also während meiner Ausbildungszeit hatten wir
ganz unten in einem Rack
noch alte, so richtig fette
4HE-Sandkisten stehen.
Ich weiß ehrlich gesagt gar nicht, was die gemacht haben.
Bis heute weiß ich nicht, was die gemacht haben.
Die waren einfach nur da und an.
Die haben wahrscheinlich seit 15 Jahren das gleiche
gemacht und die gingen einfach.
Mainstream bei Google Mail sein
oder og.gmx.de
Gmx?
Ich hab paar E-Mail-Adressen bei Gmx
und paar bei Gmail.
Die älteren von mir
die hab ich bei Gmx.
Ich hab sogar bei einer ein Gmx-Premium-Abo
für irgendwie 4€ oder so.
Für mehr IMAP-Speicher.
Matthias, danke für den Sub.
...schreiben, die eine Mail-Adresse haben.
Und Gmx hatte übrigens
letztens einen größeren Ausfall.
Die waren mal einen halben Tag nicht erreichbar.
Aber es gibt schlimmeres, was bei E-Mail
zentralisierten Diensten wie WhatsApp,
Signal oder Telegram.
Da kann man keine eigenen Server betreiben
und man hat auch keine Wahl, wo man
den eigenen Account registriert.
Aber leider hat E-Mail auch ganz viele
Nachteile. Dummerweise auch welche,
die sich prinzipbedingt auch nicht vereint.
Zum Beispiel, dass man schön Absender faken kann.
Ich mein, man kann das, ja,
mit Signaturen
und Verschlüsselungen und so, kann man E-Mail
ganz, sag mal,
ganz gut secure machen. Das Ding ist nur,
niemand verwendet's.
Einfach reparieren lassen, vor allem was die Sicherheit
angeht. Deshalb wäre es jetzt einfach
zu sagen, die Zeit ist gekommen.
E-Mail stirbt bald.
Das haben ja auch schon viele Leute gesagt.
Wir sagen aber, E-Mail ist nicht tot.
Ja, seh ich auch so.
Seht ihr in diesem Video. Und auch, warum E-Mail
nicht total kaputt ist.
Ja, seh ich auch so.
MonkaS
Hast du schon
das Half-Life Anniversary update...
Was? Was? Moment.
Was?
Was? Wo? Wo?
Ne.
Alter, die Seite laggt as fuck.
Ich glaub, wir müssen den Chrome machen,
für mehr Grafikbeschleunigung. Ja, läuft gleich viel besser.
Brrrrrrrr
Brr
So.
Wisst ihr, was mich bei Half-Life heute immer
bis heute verwirrt?
Ich gätte, warum es so ist.
Aber Black Mesa
hat überall
irgendwie radioaktives Zeug
und giftiges Zeug rumliegen.
Aber, einen Helm
hat dieser Schutzanzug nicht.
Headcrabs
würden überhaupt nicht funktionieren,
Wenn der Schutzanzug hätte aber wenn es den Helm hätte der Schutzanzug, aber die Brille macht das schon
Und was für ein Update
Ja, was gibt es jetzt hier eigentlich als Update? Chat-Gear und was sind die
New Content
Ja schön, aber
Wie weit das konnte? Wir sind doch schon unten. Ach Moment, ich dachte wir sind unten
Uplink, Uplink war die Demo
Uplink ist jetzt dabei, okay
Uplink war die die PC-Demo für Half-Life
Okay, nice
Es ist gut, dass vier neue Multiplayer-Maps
Kaum einer spielt noch. Updated Graphics-Settings
Besseres Field of View
UI-Upscaling
Restored Content, Original Main-Menü
So sah Gordon Freeman in der Alpha aus, wobei das noch nicht Gordon Freeman war, das war hier Ivan, der Space-Biker
Da erkennt man auch noch ein bisschen besser an dieser Grafik, dass Half-Life ursprünglich auf der Quake-1-Engine basiert, finde ich
also
die Multiplayer-Maps
Nun ja, es hält sich, es hält sich doch wirklich
sehr in Grenzen
Original Valve Intro Video
Improved Physics
Ganz ehrlich, wahrscheinlich nichts, was es mit Mods nicht, wir haben es ja letztens wieder durchgespielt mit M-Mod
vor einem halben Jahr oder so
Es gibt jetzt für mich keinen Grund, es nochmal durchzuspielen in nächster Zeit
Okay, gucken wir mal, das wird, wird fertig. E-Mail, wo sind wir stehen geblieben hier?
Bleibt dran
Ja, die E-Mail ist tatsächlich älter als das Internet, also genau genommen das Protokoll dahinter
SMTP, Simple Mail Transfer Protocol, das stammt nämlich aus dem Jahr
1982 und war eigentlich für
ARPANET gedacht, also dieses US-Forschungsnetzwerk, aus dem dann später das Internet hervorgegangen ist. Warum ist das wichtig?
Ich erinnere mich noch an, in der Berufsschule, wo sie uns das erklärt haben, gab es da nicht noch ALOA oder sowas als Vorgänger?
Wer, wer hat, wer hat Internet History drauf, Leute?
Gab es da nicht noch irgendein ALOA-Funk oder ALHOLA oder irgendwie so ähnlich ALOA
Funk-Netzwerk, wo sie damals auch schon getestet haben, Netzwerk-Collisions und sowas
Das Funk-Netz der Unis auf Hawaii
Ja, genau
Irgendwie, ich erinnere mich noch dunkel dran
Okay, wir können mal gucken, was die Game, was die Gamestar dazu sagt
Dadurch einiges Erklärendes, womit sich die E-Mail heute noch herumschlägt
ARPANET war nämlich ganz anders als das Internet, quasi so ein Friede-Freude-Eierkuchen-Netzwerk, weil es nur von einer kleinen Forschung
und Militär-Bubble benutzt wurde, gab es da keine kriminellen Angriffe, Spam oder Betrugsmaschen
Und dieses SMTP-Protokoll verwenden Mails aber noch heutzutage
Gab es am Anfang im Internet auch nicht so viel, umso Mainstreamiger das Ganze geworden ist, umso mehr hat es zugenommen, logischerweise
Ja, um miteinander zu kommunizieren
Wo viele Leute sind, ist viel Geld zu holen, dann sind die Scammer auch nicht weit
Und wo viel, wo der Mainstream die Leute sind, haben die auch weniger Technikahnung und lassen sich einfacher scammen
Bei SMTP sind nicht Benutzer oder Organisationen im Mittelpunkt, sondern Prozesse auf Computern
Das Ganze ist im Prinzip super simpel, das erklärt euch jetzt mal Shahin, der normalerweise hinter der Kamera arbeitet
Okay, also
Der User ist ein möglicher Auslöser, der dem sendenden SMTP-Prozess den Auftrag zum Senden einer Nachricht gibt
Dieser Prozess baut dann eine Verbindung zum empfangenden Mail-Server auf und stellt sich dann mit dem Befehl Hello, also mit der Abkürzung von Hello, kurz vor
Habt ihr schon mal SMTP per Telnet gemacht?
Das geht im Vergleich zu vielen anderen Sachen relativ gut
Da müsst ihr genau sowas eintippen
Oder ein Get per Telnet ist auch relativ easy mit HTTP 1.1
Z.B. hello-mail.heise.de und liefert dann, wenn der empfangende Server bereit ist, eine Nachricht ab
Dafür muss er angeben, wie der Absender der Nachricht heißt und an wen sie gehen soll
Also z.B. mail-from-3003-at-ct.de rcpt-to-newstips-at-heise.de
Und ja, das At-Zeichen gab es auch schon 1982
Was damals aber noch niemand ahnen konnte, die Möglichkeit selbst anzugeben, von wem eine Nachricht kommt, wird später ausgenutzt für Spam und Spoofing
Spam zu verwenden ist mit SMTP super einfach
Man braucht nur ein kleines Programm, das massenhaft SMTP-Sitzungen eröffnet und dann Nachrichten bei anderen Servern ablehnt
Das ist auch oft bei Malware so passiert
Also du kriegst Schadsoftware und die versendet dann über deinen PC Spam
Da hatten wir auch schon mal ein Video dazu
Und auch das sogenannte Spoofing ist bei SMTP super einfach
Es kann jeder behaupten, dass die Mail von irgendeinem Absender kommt
Also etwa absender-at-bundeskanzleramt.de
Um dagegen vorzugehen, wurden dann später Verfahren um SMTP herumgebaut
Etwa SPF, DKIM und DMARC
Wolltest du dich irgendwie selbst geißeln?
Oder warum machst du sowas?
Also war das irgendwie Bestrafung für irgendwas?
Oder wolltest du das machen?
Kann ja sein, manche Leute peitschen sich aus
Und manche Leute programmieren in C++ und Sockets RAW unter Windows ein Mail-Client
Ach für deine Diplom-Arbeit?
Okay ja, das ist ja quasi sowas wie Selbstquälen
Ein gutes, günstiges Multimeter
Also ich kann dir nur sagen, was ich für eins hab
Ob das gut ist, weiß ich nicht
Im Vergleich zu anderen
Aber es ist günstig as fuck
Und für meine Zwecke reicht das
Hier, das ist ein
Komm her
So ein China-Chinesen-Ding ist das
Und zwar ein Track-Live-DM-01M
So ungefähr sieht das aus
So in der Richtung sieht das aus
Nur dass es nicht von IITAM ist
Also es ist halt ein China-Chinesen-Ding
Ist halt billig
Für gute bezahlst du aber 150 Euro
Das ist halt, naja
Es ist billig
Wenn du was wirklich haben willst, was sehr genau ist
Und was irgendwie
Noch irgendwie zusätzliche Features hat
Da ist es wahrscheinlich nicht so gut
Aber was ich auf jeden Fall für Multimeter empfehlen kann
Hat jetzt, ist universal
Sind so ein
Ein zusätzlicher Pack an Test-Probes
Und zwar, keine Ahnung, kann man sich ja was raussuchen
Ja, zum Beispiel ein Pack
Wo verschiedene Probes dabei sind
Dass du dann hier die hast zum Beispiel
Die du an Drähte dran klemmen kannst
Oder dass du so eine Pinzette hast
Was ich auch sehr praktisch finde
Ist hier die etwas längeren Kontakte
Als die, die dabei sind
Also ich benutze mittlerweile zu 90% nur noch die hier
Die hier
Die kann man so raus machen
Die kann man so rausfahren
Da kommt also hier vorne, das ist eigentlich
Da ist ein Draht drinnen
Man drückt hier hinten drauf
Dann kommt hier vorne ein Draht raus
So mit einem Haken dran
Den hackt man ein, dann lässt man los
Da hinten ist eine Feder drin
Und dann bleibt der Haken halt quasi am Draht hängen
Wo man, und das ist halt mega praktisch
Weil ich ja meistens das an irgendwelche Drähte, Kabel
Was auch immer machen will
Bei irgendwelchen kleinen Schaltungen
Und da sind die reinen Probes
Wo man einfach nur dagegen halten muss
Manchmal unpraktisch
Ja, so ein zusätzliches Pack aus Probes
Kann ich jedem empfehlen
Und am besten, ihr kauft euch die
Mit den elastischen Kabeln
Weil oftmals sind die Kabel, die dabei sind
Richtig Schrott
Am besten ist
Es gibt welche, die haben so super elastische Kabel
Die sind sehr, sehr nice
Ja, ansonsten habe ich keine großartige Empfehlung
No, God!
Please, no!
No!
Wir fangen jetzt aber nicht davon an
Wir gucken jetzt das Video weiter
Pass mal auf, Modern Seed, sorry Leute
Haha, jetzt muss es
Wir hatten doch letztens sowas schönes
Das ist auch eklig
Wir hatten doch, ich finde
Ich finde es nicht mehr
Sorry
So, also
Hier
Wo wir gerade dabei sind
Modernes C++ ist schön
Also, der Typ, der fragt von neun Jahren
Ich gebe zu, das ist schon ein bisschen her
Aber das ist ein gutes Beispiel
Der fragt von neun Jahren
Wie kann man in C++ sowas hier machen
Wie in C Sharp
Das Arrayfilter nach
Nach nem
Nach ner Bedingung
Also, das Arrayfilter nach ner bestimmten Bedingung
Ja, zum Beispiel Elemente größer als zwei
Die akzeptierte Antwort ist das hier
Ich meine seriously
The fuck
Standard copy if
Who begin
Who end
Standard backinserter
Was niemand weiß
Dass es das gibt überhaupt
Weißes halt
Und dann diese tolle Lambda-Syntax
Das ist normal
Wenn es um C++ geht, muss das immer sein
Also, wenn ich das hier sehe
Pass mal auf
Die Leute wollten sich jetzt noch übertreffen
In diesem
Backinserter
Die Leute wollten sich jetzt mit den Antworten
Hier übertreffen
Und Leute, es wird immer schlimmer
Ich finde das hier schon mega hässlich
Übrigens, ich verstehe nicht
Warum bei den 5
Also hätte, erstens
Hätte C++ sowas wie Extension Methods
Was es schon sehr lange als Proposal gibt
Aber die nicht wollen
Wäre super easy sowas zu implementieren
Aber, warum man nicht für die 5
Meistbenutzten Standardcontainer
Sowas anbietet
Weiß ich nicht
Das Emote ist mega nice
Die Leute haben sich jetzt gedacht
Wir müssen das noch übertreffen
Also das ist ja
Das ist schon eklig
Aber es wird noch besser
In C++ kann man das Ganze
Nämlich so schreiben
Die C++ Leute haben sich nämlich gedacht
Ey, weißt du was
Anstatt dass wir Vector
Eine Filtermethode spendieren
Sodass man sagen könnte
Vector, Filter
Gibt es jetzt was neues
Ranges
Was man aus irgendwelchen Gründen
Mit einem overloadeten Pipe Operator macht
Alter
Warum
Also erstens, warum kann man den Pipe Operator
Überhaupt overloaden
Und warum sich eine komplett
Neues Ding ausdenken
Was es vorher in der Sprache nicht gegeben hat
Um das zu filtern
Also das ist schon
Es mag ein bisschen kürzer
Und vielleicht ein bisschen eingängiger sein
Aber trotzdem echt weird champ as fuck
Und warum, warum
So
Javascript
Hat genauso Schwachsinn
Mein Lieblings Beispiel ist immer noch hier
Leeres Array gleich gleich nicht leeres Array
Is by the way true
Oder was auch nice ist
Ähm
New Array join A-M
Batman
Kommt das hier raus
Man versteht Javascript auch nicht
Und aber jetzt
Die Leute haben sich gedacht
Die Antworten
Sind immer noch nicht gut genug
Und die Antworten sind ja auch
Halbwegs aktuell
Jetzt kommt der nächste
Und sagt
Wie wärs denn mit Boost
Erstmal
Für das Filtern von einem Array Boost
Inkluden
Logisch, was sonst
Wie könnte man auch davon ausgehen
Dass die Standard Library
Einer Sprache
Das Filtern einer Liste
Irgendwie benutzerfreundlich erlaubt
Also das ist ja
Undenkbar, ne
Welche Programmiersprache hat schon
Die Möglichkeit Arrays zu filtern
Also jetzt kommt Boost rein
Daraus wird das hier gemacht
Das ist finde ich
Schonmal nicht besser als das davor
Weil man versteht es wirklich gar nicht mehr
Elements werden gepiped
Nachfiltert
Dann was auch immer
Deckel Type, Elements, Value Type
Sonst
Also
Was auch immer hier passiert an der Stelle
Und dann wird gefiltert
So und dann haben sie sich gedacht
Das reicht immer noch nicht
Es reicht immer noch nicht
Jetzt wird es mit
Templates erweitert
Es reicht immer noch nicht
Jetzt machen wir Templates
Drumherum oder irgendwas
Moment sind das überhaupt schon Templates
Nee sind noch keine Templates
So und jetzt hört es
Komplett aus
Ich hab keine Ahnung mehr was hier eigentlich passiert
Jetzt ist es durch
So und der nächste hat sich gedacht
Das reicht immer noch nicht
Lass uns ein Template draus bauen
Wir reden hier
Leute mal ganz hell
Wir reden hier davon eine Liste
Mit Elementen zu filtern
Also quasi eines der absoluten Basics
Was du mit einer Liste
Machen willst
So jetzt kommen sie an
Und bauen hier irgendwelche komischen Templates drumherum
Das ist ihnen immer noch nicht genug
Jetzt gibt es hier noch advancere Templates
Leute es ist so weird
Champig
Ich komm einfach nicht klar drauf
Wisst ihr
Ernsthaft es gibt
Es gibt ja nicht viele
Es gibt
Eine Handvoll
Wirklich viel benutzter
Collections
Container in C++
Das ist Vector
Das ist vielleicht noch
Queue und Stack
Und dann noch 1,2 der Dictionary
Dinger
Und warum
Kann man diesen Dingern
Nicht einfach ein paar neue Methoden spendieren
Zum Beispiel sowas wie Filter
Oder Count
Oder sowas
So schwer
Kann es doch nicht sein
Dann hast du 90% der Fälle
Abgedeckt
Aber C++ ich weiß eh nicht was das C++
Gremium macht
Okay wir gucken jetzt weiter
Die haben kein Count
Vielleicht hab ich jetzt Mist erzählt
Aber ich glaube die haben kein Count
Moment
Wo bin ich hier gelag
Ah
C++ Container
Hier hatte ich das auf
Haben die Count
Vector
Begin, End, Size
Ja Moment
Die haben kein Count
Die haben Size
Aber Size ist nicht gleich Count
Weil Size bedeutet
Wie groß die Collection
Gerade
Memorytechnisch
Wie viel Platz die Collection gerade hat
Also mal angenommen
Du
Ich bin mir nicht sicher wie Vector unter der Haube das macht
Also normalerweise passiert das ja so
Bei
Collections
Die
Nicht eine fixe Länge haben
Wie beispielsweise die Standard
C-Arrays
Da machen die das ja so
Damit sie eben
Nicht so oft neues Memory
Anfordern müssen und kopieren
Dass die immer ums Doppelte erweitert wird
Also zum Beispiel
Man hat eine Liste
Man legt einen Vector an
Ich vermute einfach mal das es so funktioniert
Ich bin mir nicht sicher wie es C++ macht
Ob das überhaupt definiert ist
Oder ob das pro Implementierung abhängt
Zumindest in Internet weiß ich das es so ist
Also die machen das so
Mal angenommen du legst einen Vector an
Und schreibst am Anfang 5 Initial
Dann
Fügst du ein 6. Element ein
Und der Vector ist nicht groß genug
Jetzt könnte der ja
Speicher anfordern für 6 Elemente
Alle Elemente rüber kopieren
Das ist aber auf Dauer ein bisschen zu lahm
Deswegen fordert er Speicher für 10 Elemente an
Wenn du das 11. Element
Einfügst
Dann macht er aus 10 Elementen 20 Elementen
Wenn du das 21. Einfügst
Fordert er 40 an
Wenn du das 41. Einfügst fordert er 80 an
Also Collections
Resizen sich oftmals immer so
Zumindest am Anfang immer um das Doppelte
Das heißt
Ich bin mir nicht sicher
Ob Size
Wirklich
Count ist der Elemente die drin ist
Oder
Die
Theoretisch
Verfügbare Menge
Return Size
Leider ist die Hilfe auch nicht
Also
Capacity würde ich sagen ist auf jeden Fall das
Was ich sage aber bei C++ weiß man nie so genau
Size
Returns the number of elements in a Vector
Dann ist Size tatsächlich
Sowas wie Count
Hat denn
Sowas wie
Stack zum Beispiel
Immerhin
Also man sieht die Collections in C++
sind äußerst minimalistisch
Das ist ja nicht als hätten die
Viel ja und ich
Finde also so eine Filter Methode
Wäre doch echt jetzt
Durchaus in Ordnung gewesen
Die haben ja nichts im Endeffekt
Hätte C++ sowas eine
Möglichkeit bestehende Klassen zu
Erweitern wäre das mega
Weil dann könnte man sich einfach
Irgendeine Utility Collections
Library inkluden und die
Standard Collections hätten auf einmal
Filter Max Min
Durchschnitt und alles mögliche
Aber ja geht ja in C++
Nee richtig
Okay weiter im Text
Eigentlich wollte ich das E-Mail Video gucken
Dafür gibt es Templates
Ja aber mit Templates kannst du jetzt nicht
Zum Beispiel Vector
Eine Filter Methode verpassen
Ich meine okay
Ich will nicht ausschließen dass man das mit Vectors nicht doch machen kann
Mit Vectors kann man
Mit Templates nicht doch machen kann
Mit Templates kann man irgendwie
Vectors machen irgendwie wenn man weiß wie
Aber ich glaube das geht nicht
Ja aber ich finde das blöd
Dann läuft das auf sowas raus
Backinserter
Standard Copy If
Warum nicht
Einfach in die 5 meist
Benutzten Collections eine Filter Methode einbauen
Das ist doch 90% das
Sag mal guck mal
Es werden zu 90% so 5 Standard Collections
Verwendet und zum Filtern
Wird zu 90% von diesen
90% verwendeten Collections
Möchte man eben den Inhalt
Filtern mit irgendeinem Callback
Warum kann man
Warum kann man das nicht einfach
Einbauen
So wird champig
Man könnte es ja durchaus auch anbieten
Als hier
Standard Filter
Sonst was aber eben
Bei den Collections halt eine
Methode einfügen
Die Filter heißt die im Zweifelsfall
Die im Zweifelsfall
Einfach
Das eben für die Standard
Für die 5 meist benutzten Standard Collections
Mit irgendwas was schon
Vorhanden ist im Framework halt
Wrapped nochmal
Übrigens die C++ Standard Library
Hat bis heute kein HTTP Client
Jetzt kommen die Leute
Sagen Rust auch nicht
Aber ich finde eine moderne Sprache sollte das haben
Und selbst wenn man sagt
Es ist irgendwie Optional
Das Problem ist halt auch dass es keine
Standard Implementierung der C++ Standard Library
Gibt wofür das C++
Cremium irgendwie zuständig wäre
Ich meine es gibt so
De facto Standards
Du hast die
GCC Sache und du hast die
LLVM
Geschichte
Aber
Wenn die
Ich bin mir sicher wenn das C++ Cremium
Den Shit den die sich
Ausdenken selbst auch
Implementieren müssten wäre vieles besser
Gelöst
Ja es ist auch noch so ein Ding
Ja so ist es echt
Es ist auch so ein Ding
Du kannst in jeder Programmiersprache
Die mir so einfällt also
Vor jeder halbwegs modernen
Programmiersprache kannst du
Weil das hier auch ein schönes Beispiel
Kannst du einfach
Hast du einfach irgendeine
Date Duration was auch immer klasse
Dann sagst du Date Time Now
Und das ganze bitte
Den Sekundenanteil
Und den Sekundenanteil bitte in Millisekunden
Ist eigentlich super
Easy
So und jetzt kommt die C++ Variante
Und das geht noch
Das geht noch es gibt
Es gibt schlimmere
Aber ich meine seriously
Okay also erstmal
Das ganze hier um Time Now
Das ist okay das lasse ich mir gefallen
So dass man Zeiten
Voneinander abziehen kann und am Ende
Kommen Sekunden raus auch okay
So
Aber was ist das hier denn schon bitte schön wieder
Standard Krono
Duration Cast
Microseconds
Was ein Alias ist für
Standard Krono Milliseconds
Sorry Milliseconds nicht
Microseconds also eigentlich
Korrekt geschrieben wäre das Standard Krono
Duration Cast
Standard Krono Milliseconds
Ähm
Hier musst du dann halt Seconds reinstecken
Weil du es wissen musst
Und das artet
Komplett aus man
Guckt euch das an man
Und das ist noch eines der einfacheren Sachen
In der Standard Library
MonkaS alter
Wir brauchen das hier
Ja für C++ passt das
12 different ways
To filter containers in modern C++
Okay Leute
Sorry für Side getrackt werden
Aber ich muss ein bisschen ranten über C++ jetzt
Wir brauchen
Ja
Hat noch keiner ein sinnvolles Emote
Gebastelt
Ich bin selbst zu faul
Also ich muss sagen es macht durchaus Sinn
In manchen Bereichen C++ zu verwenden
So ist es nicht ich mag die Sprache
Plus nicht zum Beispiel ESP32
Microcontroller
Das waren 1024 x 1024
Das waren 1024 Bilder
Ähm
Also ESP32 macht Bock zu programmieren
Auch in C++
Aber viele Sachen
Die sich ausgedacht haben sind halt pp
An String erinnert
Okay
12 different ways to filter
Containers in modern
Also das Ding ist halt schonmal
Warum gibt es überhaupt 12 different ways
Zu Container zu filtern
Was ich brauche
Also deine Twitch Emotes sind
32 x 32
128 x 128
Keine Ahnung
Aber dein Emote war auch nicht
Keck genug
Oder
Okay was haben wir
Filter raw weg
Okay das geht
Also das ist ja noch
Irgendwie
Also ich finde das hier schon nicht gut
We can use it like
Ich persönlich fände es besser man könnte schreiben
Weg.filter
Okay aber das geht ja nicht
Okay 12
Good old raw loops
Das ist der go away
Warum muss das in der Welt
In einem Template sein
Achso ja weil
Weil die Elemente ja unterschiedlich sein können
Okay verstehe verstehe macht Sinn
Also das ist der go away
Das ist auch so ein Ding wo ich immer
Bei den go Leuten
So nach dem Motto ey ich hab ne Liste und würde die gerne
Filtern die Antwort der go Leute
Ist immer ja loop just loop
Loop and if
Ist die Standard Antwort von den go Leuten
Wobei ich glaube mittlerweile
Dadurch das go
Wenn auch etwas paints champige
Generics mittlerweile generics hat
Glaube ich das ist mittlerweile
Halbwegs brauchbar ich glaube ich weiß
Es nicht ja vielleicht kennt ihr eine
Ich glaube es gibt mittlerweile auch halbwegs
Sinnige
Generic go libraries zum
Filtern von Listen
Die gibt es schon länger die waren halt aktuell
In go also die waren ne ganze Zeit lang in go
Richtig schlecht weil die alle quasi
Ja nur object verwendet haben
Also wie heißt das denn wie heißt das denn go
In interface Klammer auf Klammer zu
Also ganz ehrlich ich wüsste
Nicht wie ich den Array anders filtern soll
Für Spiele Programmierung als für microcontroller
Programmierung
Letztendlich ist es ne Schleife mit nem if drinne
Man kann doch eine
Sinnvolle
Default Implementierung wählen
Und jeder der das Array anders
Anders filtern möchte
Kann das ja selbst machen wenn er da
Bock drauf hat und das für ihn nicht passt
So macht das jede x beliebige andere Sprache auch
Es gibt ne guck mal
Zum Beispiel Suchalgorithmen
Die meisten Programmiersprachen bieten
Mittlerweile ne Sort Methode
Was übrigens glaube ich
C++ für Vector auch nicht hat
C++
Vector Sort ich glaube gibt es auch nicht oder
Ne dafür gibt es Standard Sort
Also so gut wie jede Programmiersprache bietet an
Das man beispielsweise
Listen sortieren kann
Die haben ne halbwegs sinnvolle
Default
Sortier Algorithmus die meisten haben so ne Mischung
Aus Quicksort für längere Sachen
Und irgendwie frag mir nicht
Irgendwas was schnell ist für kleinere Sachen
Okay und das
Switch nie anhand der Länge die haben ne sinnvolle
Default Implementierung wenn jetzt einer sagt ey
Für meinen Anwendungsfall ist die Default
Quicksort Implementierung Kacke
Da kann er das ja
Was eigenes verwenden
Und das könnten die bei C++ genauso machen
Eine sinnvolle Default Implementierung
Die für sagen wir mal 90% der Fälle gut ist
Und ich meine ein Array zu filtern
Ja ne Schleife drüber zu machen
Mit nem if drinne ist glaube ich
Erstmal ne ganz sinnvolle Default Implementierung
Und
Ja C Sharp macht das auch C Sharp verwendet auch
Ne Mischung aus Heapsort
Quicksort und noch was
Fürs Sortieren
Okay
Raw Loops damit gehe ich
D'accord das passt
Was richtig advanced wär Chatge
Was richtig cool wär
Wenn man keinen neuen Vektor
Allocaten müsste sondern
Einfach nur einen View
In den alten Vektor liefern könnte
Mit den gefundenen Elementen
Falls das
Irgendwie geht
Also das finde ich durchaus sinnvoll
Ne Schleife und drüber okay weiter gehts
Filter by standard copy if
Okay seriously das hatten wir gerade schon
Keiner checkt was es
Ja doch man checkt schon aber umständlich
Remove copy if
Okay im Prinzip
Im Prinzip das umgedrehte
Es wird nicht kopiert in was neues
Sondern es wird
Removed das nur noch das übrig bleibt
Was man haben will
The famous remove
The famous remove erase
Was okay was
Auto Vektor
Chat warum
Übergeben die hier einen Vektor und weisen den
Neu zu
Out erase
Standard remove if
Begin end
Standard not fnp end
Ääääääääääääääää
Was zum
Was
Creates a forwarding call
Wrapper that returns
The negation of the
Callable object
Hä
Ich hab das jetzt gelesen ich weiß nicht was die
Mir sagen wollen
Was
Was anderes
Fällt mir dazu echt nicht mehr ein wenn ich das sehe
Alter
Okay das ist nichts
Was man selbst schreiben muss das ist ja quasi nur die
Definition was du da reinschieben kannst
Einmal gibt es irgendjemanden der das hier lesen kann
Äh
Exzellentes Beispiel
Haha
Irgendjemand der die Docs gelesen hat
Hat sich gedacht dieses Beispiel
Ist die perfekte Demonstration
Für dieses Feature
Niemand kann es lesen niemand versteht es
What the fuck man
Template class
Punkt Punkt Punkt
Enable if t
Negate invokable
Haha
Konstexe Deckel type
Auto Operator
Arx und und
Punkt Punkt Punkt
Arx
Konst und und
Ausrufe Zeichen
Standard
Move forward
Arx
Ey
Die sind
Die sind einfach echt
Okay
Es wird immer moderner Leute
Es wird immer moderner
Adding some C++
Standard erase if
Out
Not fn
Man könnte fast sagen es ist lesbar
Nur mit dem Unterschied dass keiner checkt was es eigentlich
Macht
Und warum eine Function
Not a Function ist verstehe ich nicht
Moment
Ich verstehe was es macht
Das führt das aus
Und
Ich verstehe bloß nicht
Warum man dafür was braucht
Das führt das aus
Der Return Wert ist ein Bool
Der macht im Prinzip einfach
Der macht ein Ausrufe Zeichen davor
Das ist quasi er führt das aus und das Ergebnis
Ist Not
Aber warum
Braucht man dafür Standard Not fn
Warum kann ich nicht
Warum kann ich nicht einfach schreiben
Ups
Jetzt mal
Äh Code
What
Code
Warum kann ich nicht einfach schreiben
Sag
Einfügen
Visual Studio Code
Warum kann ich nicht einfach schreiben
Ähm
P entweder so
Oder
Warum kann ich nicht einfach
Zweifel
Im Zweifelsfall mach ich halt
So
Ich meine es ist
Dank der ekligen C++
Aber ich finde das immer noch besser als Standard Not fn
Ja das ich es nicht direkt callen kann
Verstehe ich
Aber ich meine
Das müsste doch mehr oder weniger
Äquivalent dazu sein oder
Ach Moment hier kommt ja noch
Moment hier kommt noch x rein
So müsste das sein
Weil wir bekommen ja quasi
Ein Element pro
Das hier wäre doch vollkommen okay oder
Not fn ist ein richtiger
Kackname du denkst es ist not a function
Dabei ist es einfach
Das müsste negate fn oder sowas
Heißen irgendwie dann würdest du es verstehen
Aber ich meine ganz ehrlich
Das hier würde also ich würde es eh anders
Bei mir würde das Ding beispielsweise
Nicht p
Heißen sondern sagen wir mal irgendwie
Filter oder sowas oder einfach nur
Callback irgendwie sowas in der Richtung
Oder Filter Callback
Irgendwie sowas würde ich das nennen
Also ich finde das hier wäre jetzt halbwegs
Lesbar oder dann würde man verstehen
Was es macht
Es bekommt ein Element ich bin mir übrigens nicht sicher
Welche C++ ist aber ich finde es
Lesbar du bekommst ein Element
Pro Durchlauf schiebst
Das in die Filterfunktion und am
Ende das returnt ein bool und am
Ende negatest du das
Und am besten wäre es wenn du nicht mal
Die Klammern brauchst weil es
Einfach nur ein Ausdruck ist
Und man könnte im Endeffekt sowas
Machen aber ey ey das
Ist glaube ich
Das war nicht im Scope für das
C++ Kremium das irgendwie lesbar zu machen
Muss X nicht eine Referenz sein
Doch kann sein
Also naja gut
Das wäre vielleicht ein bisschen lesbarer
Egal weiter was können wir sonst noch machen
Ich weiß ich bin hyper sidetracked
Aber ein bisschen C++ Flame muss sein
Ich finde
Das hier nicht lesbarer als eine Schleife
Ehrlich gesagt
The famous remove
Das hatten wir doch gerade schon
Das ist wieder was anderes
Hä?
Adding some C++ 20 ranges
Standard ranges copy if
Backinserter
Macht es auch nicht schöner
Making it more generic
Okay jetzt kommt der Abfuck mit
Irgendwelchen Templates drumherum
Alter
Ja ist klar
Also ich habe ja gestern schon darüber geflamed
Das Rust teilweise schwer lesbar ist
Okay
Es ist eine generic Function mit
Einem Parameter
Typ T
Das ergibt Sinn
Das ist quasi das gleiche wie wenn ich in C sharp schreiben würde
Ja
T und P oder so
Bloß dass es komplizierter ist
Return Typ Auto
Filter
Parameter
Er checkt zur Compile Zeit
Jetzt hört es schon wieder auf
Const
Expr
Das ist Compile Time Magic
Has pushback
Ah
Okay ich verstehe
Die checken ob die Collection auf die man das
Anwendet eine Methode
Has pushback hat
Es ist mega cool dass C++
Sowas erlaubt so Compile Time Checks
Das ist richtig pock
Macht es aber unnötig kompliziert
Ich finde
Diese Compile Time Auswertung
Ist eines der geilsten Features von C++
Aber auch gleichzeitig
Eines dessen was es zu dieser
Ausgeburt der Hölle an Programmiersprache
Macht die es ist
Mitmacht dazu was es ist
Also sie checken hier quasi zur Compile Time
Ob der Vector Typ den man hier eben
Also der Collection Typ
Den man hier reingeschoben hat
Ob der eine Methode Has pushback hat
So wenn er das hat
Dann verwendet er Standard Copy If
Back Inserter
Wenn er das nicht hat
Dann verwendet er Standard Copy If
Inserter
Macht Sinn
Wenn die mal sowas wie Extension Methods hätten
Könnte man eine richtig schöne Sprache draus machen
Okay
Wir waren eigentlich
Sig hat aber auch
Eklige Syntax
Sig hat irgendwie
Punkt Stern Punkt Stern und so komische Dinger
So
Wir waren eigentlich
Wie wir jetzt super krass side getrackt sind
Aber auch nicht
Eigentlich waren wir gerne dabei uns ein Video
Darüber anzugucken
Das Email am Arsch ist
Aber trotzdem da bleiben wird
Was ich übrigens ganz genauso sehe
Hast du mal C++ länger
Programmiert
Naja
Länger ist Definitionssprache
Ich bastle öfters mal eigene
C++ ESP32
Firmware
Und das ist halt C++
die die Standard Library vom Hersteller, aber ich verwende ganz gern die Standard Library vom Hersteller mit ein bisschen Arduino-Library-Stelz obendrauf
und das ist C++, das heißt ich programmiere die ESP32 immer in C++.
Wir haben, wir haben ja, und das, also ganz ehrlich, ich glaube das Advancedste, was ich bisher je in C++ programmiert habe, ist das hier gewesen.
Das muss ich, ähm, im Archiv, hier FFm, oh, ist das Archiv-Proc'n, Leute?
Max, Archiv ist Proc-, nee, ist es nicht, okay, war einfach.
Oh, oh, hier, Massive, Massive neue Suche vom Archiv, Alter.
Ähm, Max, guck mal, Bug entdeckt.
Hier müsste eigentlich ein Cursor kommen, wenn man, wenn man da drüber geht, oder? Wäre viel nicer.
Aber die Seite hast du richtig Poggers gemacht.
Richtig Poggers, ich finde die mega gut, die Archiv-Seite.
So, Stream, aber hier müsste trotzdem ein Balken kommen.
Äh, FFmpeg, C++, Streamtitel.
Hier, WebAssembly, FFmpeg, C++.
Das war eines der advancedsten HiIQ-Sachen, die ich bisher gebaut habe.
Und zwar, man sieht es hier, wir haben einen Videoplayer gebaut.
Man sieht hier neben auch Video abspielen.
Wir haben einen Videoplayer gebaut und jetzt, passt mal auf, haltet euch fest,
was war, hier, guck mal, das im Archiv.
Also ich habe erstens das Archiv gelobt, dass das eine mega Poggers-Seite ist,
dass du das richtig gut hingekriegt hast.
Und das zweite ist, ich glaube, hier müsste man anstatt der Hand ein Cursor anzeigen.
Äh, kein Cursor, so einen, so einen, ja, Cursor-Balken für Text.
Also einfach CSS ändern, Cursor-Modus auf Balken, ja.
Aber letztendlich sind ja nur Kleinigkeiten.
So, und zwar, was wir in dem Stream gebaut haben, ist folgendes.
Wir haben einen Videoplayer gebaut für den Browser.
Jetzt denkt ihr euch, Videoplayer im Browser gibt es doch jetzt.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Ihr seht hier vielleicht meine Test-Videodateien.
Ich hatte eine Fernsehaufnahme in PAL, 30 FPS in MPEG-2.
Und Frage an den Chat,
kann ein Browser normalerweise Fernsehaufnahmen in MPEG-2.ts abspielen?
Rein rhetorische Frage, nein, kann er nicht.
Das heißt, wir hatten eine Videodatei in einem Format,
das der Browser nicht kann.
So, und was wir jetzt gebaut haben, ist,
wir haben in C++ mit FFmpeg zusammen einen Transcoder gebaut.
Der liest die Datei ein, weil FFmpeg kann das Ganze.
Und Transcoder ist ein falsches Wort, bestimmt nicht.
Wir lesen die Datei ein in FFmpeg,
weil FFmpeg versteht ganz normales MPEG-2.ts.
Dann haben wir die einzelnen Frames extrahiert,
umgewandelt in ein Farbformat,
was ein Canvas-Element im Browser darstellen kann.
Und dann haben wir das Ganze per WebAssembly kompiliert
und im Browser laufen lassen.
Und im Hintergrund wurden die Videodateien
dynamisch gestreamt vom Server.
Das war richtig High-IQ-Stream.
Dynamisch Video gestreamt vom Server,
per WebAssembly-kompiliertes C++ im Browser laufen lassen
mit FFmpeg, dass die Videodateien rein streamt,
einzelne Frames extrahiert,
umgewandelt in ein Farbformat, was der Browser versteht
und dann auf dem Canvas rendert.
Und man muss dazu sagen, das lief ziemlich gut, Leute.
Ich habe hier kaum CPU-Last und das lief in Echtzeit.
Das war Paarlauflösung, 30 FPS.
Aber guck hier, Kodak MPEG-2 Video.
Der Browser spielt damit ein Video ab,
was der Browser normalerweise nicht abspielen könnte,
weil er keinen Kodak dafür hat.
Das ist mega nice gewesen.
Ich meine, wie praktikabel es ist,
sei mal dahingestellt, weil die meisten Leute
wollen ja vielleicht 1080p-Plus-Videos gucken,
sag mal 1080p, 60 FPS und höher Videos,
die nicht in Formaten sind heutzutage,
die der Browser kann.
Das ist ein bisschen...
Ich glaube, das Maximale, was wir hingekriegt haben,
im Browser zu rendern, waren tatsächlich
1080p, 60 FPS, nach einigem Optimieren.
Und danach war Schluss.
Aber das ist doch schon mal nicht schlecht.
So ein bisschen wie ein Browser-Plugin früher
und komplett mit WebAssembly.
Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher,
wo ich das Projekt noch rumliegen habe.
Ich muss mal kurz gucken.
Habe ich das alte Projekt hier eigentlich noch irgendwo?
Wie hieß das denn?
MonkaCPP.
Ich muss gerade mal kurz gucken,
ob ich das noch irgendwo habe.
Das ist hier.
Ah, da ist es noch.
MonkaCPP.
Ich habe den Source-Code sogar noch.
Hier, Repos, MonkaCPP.
Da ist alles noch.
Man könnte fast mal überlegen,
das irgendwann noch mal schön zu machen
und auf GitHub zu pushen,
weil ich glaube, dafür ein Exempel
wäre für viele Leute hilfreich.
Das war nämlich wirklich nicht straightforward.
Es gibt ein paar Beispiele für C++ WebAssembly mit FFmpeg,
aber die benutzen immer nur statische Videofiles.
Wir haben ja wirklich das Video gestreamt
vom Server in den Browser.
Also man musste nicht vorher
sich 500 MB Video runterladen.
Nein, nein, man hat sich immer nur
Häppchenweise Video runtergeladen.
Ich mache das mal kurz hier in Visual Studio Code auf,
gucke mir mal meinen eigenen Kram an.
Sorry, heute nicht super SideTrack-Stelz am Start,
aber hier HTML-Index.
Genau, hier in das Canvas wird das am Ende gerendert.
mp4info.js, das ist irgendwas übrig geblieben,
das ist nichts von mir.
So, dann haben wir sogar noch irgendwelche...
Genau, wir rendern ja sogar...
Moment, das ist ja noch advancer, als ich gedacht habe.
Wir rendern sogar ja ein paar WebGL rein.
Wir rendern ja sogar noch Grafikkarten
accelerated in das Canvas rein.
So.
Und am Ende streamt der irgendwie
vom Server runter das Ganze.
Hier mp4info.
What the fuck, das ist generated auf jeden Fall.
Server.js,
Worker.js,
Render.js.
Was zum Geier!
Das haben wir doch im Leben
nicht selbst geschrieben hier, oder?
What the fuck?
Ah ne, das habe ich copy-pasted von GitHub.
Das ist Colorspace Conversion,
also von RGB zu UV,
als WebGL Shader.
Alter, das Projekt ist ja advancer gewesen,
als ich das in Erinnerung habe.
Colorspace Conversion als GPU Shader.
Meine Güte, das ist ja super advancer Shit,
was wir hier gebaut haben, ey.
Kann ich mich überhaupt noch mal richtig dran erinnern.
MonkaS, man!
Das habe ich gemacht,
weil das normale Canvas gelaggt hat.
Ja, okay.
Und wo ist hier das Streamen gewesen vom Server?
Ah hier, Fetch, Fetch, genau.
Hier, Fetch.
Reader.
Richtig.
Was passiert mit dem Reader?
Ah, das habe ich irgendwie auskommentiert,
weil es irgendwie kaputt war.
Kann das sein?
Fetch Video.
Was auch immer, es hat funktioniert.
Man sieht es ja im Stream.
Okay.
Jetzt genug Sidetracked, weiter geht's.
Das war wirklich ganz abgedrehtes Kram,
den wir mal gemacht haben.
Okay.
Eigentlich waren wir dabei,
ein Video zu gucken,
das E-Mail kaputt ist
und trotzdem weiter existieren wird.
Gut, ich würde sagen,
wir gucken jetzt echt das Video,
sonst wird das heute gar nichts mehr.
MatthiasDev, danke für den Sub.
Wobei, habe ich glaube ich vorhin schon gesehen, oder?
Egal, trotzdem, nice.
Nice.
Wir sind etwas abgetrifftet.
Etwas abgetrifftet ist gut.
Wir sind eine Stunde lang abgetrifftet oder so jetzt.
Ich bin zwei Stunden on
und wir haben nicht mal ein Video geguckt.
Zu drei Minuten von einem Video in zwei Stunden.
Lol.
Okay.
...at bundeskanzleramt.de
Um dagegen vorzugehen,
wurden dann später Verfahren um SMTP herumgebaut.
Etwa SPF, DKIM und DMARC.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Okay, SMTP kenne ich.
Das ist irgendwas für Spam-Trust oder sowas, glaube ich.
Das S steht nicht für Spam,
aber das ist so, dass du checken kannst,
ob das die andere Seite vertrauenswürdig ist oder sowas.
Glaube ich, glaube ich.
Der Rest sagt,
DKIM habe ich auch schon mal gehört,
kann ich jetzt aber nicht zu,
aber DMARC kenne ich gar nicht.
Wir sollten auf Grundlage von Kryptografie und DNS
für mehr Sicherheit sorgen.
Aber weil die E-Mail ja möglichst einfach zugänglich sein sollte
und es keine zentrale Steuerungsinstanz gibt,
wurden diese Sicherheitsmechanismen nie irgendwie verpflichtend eingeführt.
Ja.
Also so als Update von SMTP 1.0 auf 2.0.
Selbst Dinge, die heute eigentlich selbstverständlich sind,
wie die Transportverschlüsselung TLS,
sind nicht verpflichtend.
Es weigern sich halt nur immer mehr Mail-Server E-Mails zu empfangen,
bei denen die sogenannte obligatorische Transportverschlüsselung
nicht aktiviert ist.
Auch eine andere Entscheidung von damals
hat heute noch Konsequenzen.
Der Inhalt einer Mail nach dem damaligen Standard
darf nur aus ASCII-Zeichen gestehen.
Das sind alle Buchstaben, Zeilen und Zeichen,
die man in den USA braucht.
Aber eben keine Umlaute wie Ä oder Ü oder chinesische Schriftzeichen.
Ich dachte, das war mir gar nicht klar,
dass das so ist.
Ich dachte, das ist letztendlich von deinem Mail.
Ja gut, nee.
Wobei, macht schon Sinn,
da das Ganze ja interoperabel sein muss
mit allen anderen Mail-Servern.
Und es, glaube ich, kein Header-Feld gibt,
wo drinsteht, in welchem Encoding die E-Mail-Adresse ist.
Wobei, ich bilde mir ein,
dass ich letztens eine E-Mail-Adresse
mit Emojis drin gesehen habe irgendwo.
Ja gut, dass es im Domain-Part funktioniert,
verstehe ich.
Aber funktioniert es auch im User-Part?
Das war damals auch okay.
Und schon zeitgemäß.
Es ging ja primär darum, kurze Nachrichten zu übermitteln
auf Text-basierten Terminals oder Nadelndruckern.
Und das Ganze in den USA.
Aber gut, das hat sich dann offensichtlich später etwas geändert.
Und mit MIME, Multi-Purpose Internet Mail Extension,
gab es dann neue Spezifikationen, die quasi alles können.
Unicode-Zeichen annehmen.
In MIME gibt es auch unterschiedliche Typen für das Gleiche.
Wie viele Plaintext-Typen und sowas da alles gibt.
Und Verschachtelung von Inhalten.
Ich habe ja anfangs schon gesagt,
der große Vorteil an der E-Mail ist die dezentrale Struktur.
Das ist aber halt auch das größte Problem.
Das hat nämlich ab den 2000ern zu einer regelrechten Bälle
an Spam-Mails geführt.
Eben weil es alle benutzen
und man mit Spam super viele Leute erreicht.
Und auch wenn Spam etwas zurückgegangen ist,
laut einer Auswertung von Kaspersky Labs aus dem Jahr 2022
lag der Anteil an Spam-Mails da immer noch bei 45%.
Und alle, die schon mal einen Mail-Server selbst betrieben haben,
wissen, da den ganzen Spam zu filtern,
ist ganz schön nervenaufreibend.
Und wird jetzt mit KI-Textgeneratoren auch nicht einfacher.
Was aber noch schwieriger ist, ist das Sicherstellen,
dass andere Mail-Server meine Mails auch empfangen.
Da hatten wir bei der CT vor kurzem echte Probleme.
Ja, Google hat sie blacklistet.
Das habe ich mitgekriegt.
Und wenn ihr jetzt denkt, ja, das ist schon blöd,
weil dann konnte ja niemand mehr bei CT
an Gmail-Adressen Mails versenden.
Ja, aber es ist tatsächlich noch viel schlimmer gewesen.
Denn die Google-Server hosten nicht nur Google-Mail-Adressen,
sondern auch die Mails von vielen Unternehmen,
die ihre Mails samt Domain einfach von Google verwalten lassen.
Statt einen eigenen Mail-Server zu verwenden.
Das war ziemlich doof für uns
und das passiert auch regelmäßig anderen Firmen.
Also, dass die Reputation ihrer Mail-Domain
von Google abrupt runtergeschnupft wird
und keine Mails mehr von ihnen erhalten können.
Der Trend geht auch deshalb zu zentralen Mail-Adressen.
Bei den Google-Services bist du halt immer,
Google, so auf Gedeih und Verderben ausgeliefert.
Du kannst dann da zwar hinschreiben
und wenn du Glück hast, vielleicht in einem Monat oder so,
haben sie es mal dann verifiziert und dich wieder rausgenommen
oder irgendjemand, der keinen Bock hat, hat drauf geguckt
und dich drin gelassen.
Hast du halt gelitten, ne?
In Google, denn wenn ich jetzt für mein Unternehmen
einen eigenen Mail-Server betreibe
und dann aber immer Angst haben muss,
dass andere größere Mail-Server meine Mails nicht empfangen,
das ist nicht so gut.
Dann beiße ich halt in den sauren Apfel
und gebe zum Beispiel Google Geld an.
Ja, gebe ich dir recht.
Vor allem Outlook ist wirklich fragwürdig mittlerweile.
Also, Outlook gab es ja jetzt vermehrt Nachrichten darüber.
Moment.
Bei Outlook gab es jetzt ja vermehrt Nachrichten drüber,
dass sie den E-Mail-Inhalt scannen
und, jetzt kommt's, sogar verschlüsselte Anhänge
versuchen zu entpacken mit einer Standard-Passwort-Liste.
Also, ich stelle euch mal vor,
ihr verschickt einen Zip als E-Mail-Anhang,
warum auch immer ihr das macht,
und ihr habt als Passwort keckw123
und dieses Passwort ist auf einer Passwort-Liste,
dann verschlüsselt Microsoft euren Anhang
und scannt den auch.
Ja.
Dazu kommt, dass es jetzt immer weitere Probleme gibt.
Leute, die beispielsweise ihre E-Mail-Sachen
mit Outlook synken lassen,
mit dem Cloud-Outlook,
dann kopiert er quasi den kompletten E-Mail-Folder
in die Cloud bei Microsoft,
was viele Leute gar nicht haben wollen.
Da gab es doch letztens Outlook-Copy-Mails.
Da gab es doch letztens den ersten News-News-Post dazu.
Ja, das da zum Beispiel.
Weiß nicht, von welcher Seite.
New Outlook-Copies.
Also, es geht jetzt nicht um einen Outlook.com-E-Mail-Postfach,
sondern Outlook als E-Mail-Client, ja?
Und wenn ihr Outlook als E-Mail-Client verwendet,
kopiert, ich glaube sogar mit den Standard-Settings,
und ihr beispielsweise euren Gimmicks
oder Google-Mail-Account in der Outlook-App hinzufügt,
dann werden die Mails jetzt quasi kopiert zu Microsoft.
Ob man das will oder nicht,
ist halt schon ziemlich für den Arsch, ne?
Also, da mache ich echt einen großen Bogen drum.
Ich verwende nach wie vor Thunderbird.
Das wurde letztens geupdatet, sieht jetzt ein bisschen moderner aus,
ist aber irgendwie auch viel langsamer geworden.
Ja, Thunderbird.
Ich habe jegliche aktiven Inhalte für E-Mails aus.
Alles Plaintext angezeigt.
Meinung zum OpenAI-Drama.
Ich habe... Was für ein Drama!
Ich habe das OpenAI-Drama nicht mitbekommen.
Was ist da los?
Wir gucken jetzt erst mal das Video fertig.
...dass die das Mail-Hosting für mich übernehmen
und die Mails dann auch sicher bei Google
und den anderen großen Anbietern ankommen.
Fällt im ersten Moment auch gar nicht auf,
weil ich ja meine eigene Domain verwenden kann.
Aber das zerstört natürlich auch die Grundidee
vom dezentralen System E-Mail.
So, man kann ja nicht über die E-Mail...
Sie haben den Chef rausgeschmissen bei OpenAI.
Er hat wahrscheinlich Scheiße gebaut, oder?
Was war das Problem?
...sprechen, ohne E-Mail-Clienten zu erwähnen.
Klar, viele Mail-Anbieter wie Google, Microsoft oder Apple
bieten einen Browser-Zugang auf die eigenen Mails an.
Und am Desktop ist das inzwischen für viele Leute
der gängigste Weg.
Für einige geht es aber noch über die klassischen Mail-Programme
am Rechner oder Smartphone.
Für mich zum Beispiel, ich benutze auf allen Betriebssystemen
am liebsten Thunderbird.
Ich auch.
Das ist Open Source, was ich grundsätzlich bevorzuge.
Und seit dem Supernova-Update
sieht es auch wirklich ziemlich gut aus.
Und ist langsam S-Fuck geworden seit dem Update.
...mit den ganzen unterschiedlichen Clients.
Alle machen irgendwas anders.
Und man kann sich nie so genau drauf verlassen,
dass die E-Mail beim Empfänger auch wirklich so aussieht,
wie man sich das wünscht.
Was da helfen kann?
Blick in den Kurzschritt der E-Mail zu werfen.
Das stimmt.
HTML-E-Mails ist eh eines der dümmsten Erfindungen ever.
Ganz ehrlich.
Ich habe es schon erlebt, dass Leute ihren E-Mail-Client
auf Dark Mode oder Light Mode eingestellt haben.
Und ein Background gesetzt wurde per HTML-E-Mail.
Allerdings kein Foreground für die Schrift.
Was dann darauf rausgelaufen ist,
dass der schwarze Background mit weißer Schrift
bei ihm in der Absendermail vollkommen okay aussah.
Aber bei mir, wo ich in Thunderbird ein Light-Theme habe,
dass das nicht so ausgesehen hat.
Weil meine Schrift halt schwarz ist.
Und dann war der Hintergrund per HTML auf schwarz gesetzt.
Und meine Schrift war schwarz.
Und du musstest das komplette E-Mail markieren.
Oder umgedreht das gleiche.
Ich habe Dark Mode, das andere Light Mode.
Also HTML-E-Mails ist echt eines der größten PPGa-Sachen überhaupt.
Deswegen, mein Thunderbird steht nicht auf HTML-E-Mail
und auch nicht auf eingeschränktes HTML.
Mein Thunderbird steht auf Plain Text Only.
Weißer Adler auf weißem Grund.
Genau.
Die ostfriesische Nationalflagge.
Das kennt wahrscheinlich auch keiner mehr.
Das ist von Otto aus, frag mich nicht, 1985 oder so.
Weiter.
Da könnt ihr dann sehen, ob die E-Mail zum Beispiel eine Anlage hat.
Selfmade Eyes, danke schön.
Es kommt nämlich immer wieder mal vor,
dass Anhänge nicht angezeigt werden.
Etwa, wenn man eine Mail von Apple Mail sendet
und die dann mit Outlook.com im Browser geöffnet wird.
Was man da sonst noch genau wie herauslesen kann,
können Outlook-Anhänge nicht angezeigt werden.
Was hat er gesagt?
Etwa, wenn man eine Mail von Apple Mail sendet
und die dann mit Outlook.com im Browser geöffnet wird.
Was man da sonst noch genau ...
Also ganz ehrlich, ich habe, wie gesagt,
mein Thunderbird ja auch komplett auf Plain Text Only stehen.
Mich fuckt es immer ab,
wenn die kein Text-Fallback drin haben in ihren Mails,
sondern HTML-Only.
Manchmal ist es notwendig, dass man das umstellt.
Glücklicherweise hat DHL mittlerweile bei Tracking Codes
auch Text-Fallback,
wo man sich den Tracking Code einfach rauskopieren kann.
Aber ich glaube, Amazon hat auch Text-Fallback.
Mir fällt jetzt kein Beispiel ein,
aber ich bekomme ab und zu mal E-Mails,
wo ich reingucken muss und die haben keinen Text-Fallback
und bestehen nur aus HTML.
Das nervt mich immer richtig.
Wie ich herauslesen kann,
könnt ihr in diesem CT-Artikel nachlesen
oder ihr benutzt ein Header-Analyse-Tool.
In MX-Toolbox kopiert ihr zum Beispiel
einfach den Nachrichtenkopf der E-Mail
und bekommt dann mehr Informationen dazu.
Also beispielsweise, ob die E-Mail plausibel sein kann.
Also etwa, ob es ungültige DKIM-Signaturen gibt
oder SMTP-Server, die auf einer Blacklist stehen.
Wenn ihr euch die einzelnen Bereiche
aus der Kopfzeile erklären lassen wollt,
dann könnt ihr den Header-Analyser von Gaijin verwenden.
Aber im Zweifelsfall natürlich keine privaten E-Mails.
Ein Five-Head-Tool, um Header zu analysieren.
Zum Überprüfen von Versandbenachrichtigungen
oder Werbemails sind die Tools aber gut geeignet.
Die CT-Artikel zum Thema und die beiden Analyse-Tools
sind natürlich unten in der Beschreibung.
Ach ja, auch ganz toll.
Ich glaube, man kann sich bei Apple Mail
auf dem iPad nicht mal die Header anzeigen lassen, richtig.
E-Mail-Clients können aber auch ganz schöne Datenschleudern sein.
Das neue Outlook zum Beispiel schickt die IMAP und SMTP-Zugangsdaten.
Das ist das, was ich vorhin meinte.
Was ein Scheiß, Alter.
Vor allem in den Default-Settings, wo keiner mit rechnet.
Du denkst dir, Alter, ich benutze einen E-Mail-Client
und auf einmal synkt das mein Zeug in die Cloud irgendwo hin.
Das fand mich so...
Deswegen verwende ich den ganzen Kram nicht.
...Daten und sämtliche E-Mails
auch von Nicht-Outlook-Com-Mail-Adressen an Microsoft-Server.
Meine Kolleginnen und Kollegen bei CT
konnten beim Anlegen eines IMAP-Kontos mitschreiben,
wie Zielserver, Loginnahme und Passwort an Microsoft-Server übertragen werden.
Geil, geil.
Das will ich natürlich.
Meine E-Mail-Credentials im Klartext an Microsoft schicken, das will ich.
Das ist genau das, was ich haben will.
Warum wurde das nicht schon immer gemacht?
Das ist doch genau das, was ich will.
Alter, was ein Schwachsinn.
Vor allem, dass die Default-Settings so kacke sind.
Das heißt, Microsoft kann jetzt jederzeit ein E-Mail-Account durchsuchen.
Wenn...
Ich will Ihnen nicht mal böse Absichten unterstellen.
Ich will Ihnen nicht mal komplett böse Absichten unterstellen.
Sei es nur zur Auswertung, zu Werbezwecken oder sonst was.
Aber das sind so Dinger...
Wisst ihr, was ich daran wirklich sehr bedenklich finde mittlerweile?
Erstens, dass es gemacht wird.
Aber zweitens, dass es ganz viele Leute nicht interessiert.
Die wissen das und sagen sich dann...
Ja, ist doch gut.
Da kann Microsoft wenigstens ordentlich meine E-Mails scannen.
Dann bekomme ich auch pünktlich meine Push-Notification.
Und letztendlich ist dann alles schön gesüngt zwischen meinen Geräten.
Ist doch gut, wenn Microsoft das macht.
Dass da...
Eine Mehrzahl der Leute mittlerweile so denken.
Und außerdem, in meinen E-Mails ist doch eh nichts Geheimes drin.
Das macht doch gar nichts.
Das ist eh immer meine Lieblingsantwort.
Bis zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo beispielsweise Familienfotos verschickt werden.
Wo die Kinder zufällig im Pool baden.
Und irgendeine AI das als Kinderpornos klassifiziert.
Oder irgendwelche Texte ausgewertet werden.
Es gab doch vor ein paar Jahren mal diese Geschichte mit...
Wo einer auf seine Überweisung geschrieben hat...
Wien-Anflug um 8 Uhr oder sowas.
Wo es dann riesige Probleme gab.
Weil die gedacht haben, das wäre irgendein Plan für Terroranschläge.
Und solche Geschichten.
Also...
In der heutigen Zeit, ganz ehrlich...
Du musst einfach damit rechnen.
Bei der Menge, die da gescannt wird.
Diese Tools sind nicht perfekt.
Und selbst wenn...
Die eine Fehlerquote von 0,01% haben.
Bei den Millionen Sachen, die gescannt werden.
Erwischt das früher oder später...
Leute, die überhaupt nichts verbrochen haben.
Und ja, die Anbieter sagen immer...
Ja, dann gibt es noch eine manuelle Kontrolle.
Ja, geil.
Dann sitzt dann irgendein Peter von Microsoft Support aus Indien da.
Und guckt sich meine Familienfotos an.
Oder was auch immer.
Und im Zweifelsfall klassifiziert das auch noch falsch.
Also, das sind so Dinger...
Ganz im Ernst.
Ich finde, das birgt enorme Risiken.
Und...
Ich halte auch...
Und jetzt ist Keck-Alu-Time.
Wobei ich das gar nicht mal für sehr viel Keck-Alu halte.
Ich glaube, diese ganzen Einwände...
Dass die Sachen gescannt werden müssen.
Oder Verschlüsselung aufgebrochen werden muss.
Teilweise sogar noch gesetzlich vorgeschrieben und sowas.
Ich glaube ja...
Das ist der Grund mit Kinderpornos, Rassismus...
Äh, nicht Rassismus.
Kinderpornos haben sie immer.
Und terroristischen Anschlägen.
Und Morde aufklären und sowas.
Und Kindesentführungen und sowas.
Dass das alles nur vorgeschoben ist.
Weil das Punkte sind, wo keiner was dagegen sagen kann.
Weil niemand wird sagen...
Nein, ich will nicht, dass dagegen was unternommen wird.
Also...
Wer will das wirklich sagen?
Ähm...
Letztendlich bietet das aber Tür und Tor.
Um damit noch ganz andere Sachen anzustellen.
Jetzt nicht nur, sagen wir mal, von offizieller Stelle.
Sondern eben auch von den Anbietern.
Die dann letztendlich gezieltere Werbung machen können.
Die im Zweifelsfall deine Daten auswerten können.
Für irgendwelche anderen Dinger im Zweifelsfall weiterverkaufen können.
Das sind alles Sachen, die man nicht haben will.
Und das Doofe daran ist halt...
Dass das quasi mit in Kauf genommen wird.
Dadurch, dass man eben Vorschub...
Dass man das so vorschiebt, diese Themen.
Terrorismus, Kinderpornos und so.
Wo keiner was dagegen sagen kann.
Und wenn es dann erst mal da ist.
Dann wird das erweitert.
Jedes Jahr wird es weiter aufgebohrt.
Demnächst wird dann gesagt.
Ja, aber bei Urheberrechtsverletzungen...
Könnten wir doch auch mal reingucken.
Und das ist ja sicherlich nicht das 1. Beispiel, wo sowas passiert ist.
Wenn man mal historisch guckt.
Ganz viele Sachen, wo Datenschutzbedingungen gelockert wurden.
Das ging immer weiter.
Mein Lieblingsbeispiel dafür ist...
Ich muss Kekalu da lassen.
Wo sie zur Corona-Zeit gesagt haben, man soll Listen.
Man soll sich eintragen.
Wann man wo Ansprechpartner im Restaurant gewesen ist.
Und diese Listen werden rein zweckgebunden verwendet.
Zum Nachvollziehen für Corona-Infektionen.
Ich fand das sinnvoll zum damaligen Zeitpunkt.
Ist doch sinnig, wenn rauskommt, dass irgendeiner im Restaurant Corona hat.
Dass sie mich anrufen können.
Klingt sinnig.
Für diesen eingeschränkten Verwendungszweck war das auch sinnig.
Aber was kam danach?
3 Wochen später kam die bayerische Polizei um die Ecke.
Und hat gemeint, wir haben da doch Soldaten.
Wer sich wo wie aufgehalten hat.
Es wurde direkt wieder aufgeweicht.
Es wird eingeführt mit nach außen hin offensichtlich guten Intentionen.
Wer will was gegen Terrorismus, Kinderporno, Aufklärung.
Wer will dagegen was sagen.
Das ist richtig und richtig.
Aber wenn das erst mal da ist.
Wird das jedes Mal ein kleines Stückchen weiter erweitert.
Und die Anbieter haben wahrscheinlich nichts dagegen.
Die können dann sagen, wir sind gesetzlich dazu verpflichtet.
Das Ganze zu scannen und zu durchsuchen.
Bei der Gelegenheit können wir die Daten, die wir ausgewertet haben,
bei der Gelegenheit können wir die Daten, die wir ausgewertet haben,
auch weiter benutzen.
Aber macht euch keine Gedanken.
Und als nächstes kommt dann die ganze Urheberrechtsindustrie an und sagt,
ja aber guck mal, dann scannt doch bitte auch mal die Cloud,
ob da nicht einer illegal MP3s hochgeladen hat oder sowas.
Das geht ja gar nicht.
Und nach genug Lobbyarbeit hast du dann auf einmal,
dass deine Clouddaten gescannt werden nach illegalen MP3s.
Die eventuell gar nicht illegal sind, weil du sie selbst von deiner CD hast.
Und dann wird das immer weiter aufgeweicht und irgendwann gibt es kaum noch Grenzen dafür.
Ich sehe das enorm skeptisch,
diese ganzen indirekten Syncs überall hin per Default Settings
und das zunehmend automatische Auswählen und Durchsuchen von Daten,
die eigentlich die Anbieter und keinen außer die Besitzer was angeht.
Also im Prinzip gibt es nur eine Variante dagegen.
Wenn man Cloudstorage verwendet, verschlüsselt hochladen.
Und auch wenn ihr nichts zu verbergen habt.
Ich behaupte nämlich mal, die meisten Leute haben nichts super krass Kriminelles zu verbergen.
Aber trotzdem Festplatte verschlüsseln, Cloudsachen verschlüsseln.
Das ist das einzige wie man sich dagegen schützen kann.
Und es hat den weiteren Vorteil, wenn ihr eine Festplatte benutzt, die nur verschlüsselt ist
und die mal kaputt geht, könnt ihr sie einfach in den Müll schmeißen
und ihr müsst euch keine Gedanken machen, dass irgendeiner eure privaten Nudes
und ihr mal kaputt geht, könnt ihr sie einfach in den Müll schmeißen
oder was auch immer ihr da habt, irgendwie von der Platte restored.
Also Festplatte per Default, bevor was draufgeschrieben wird, verschlüsseln.
Kann ich euch echt nur empfehlen.
Und ist performance-technisch überhaupt kein Problem heutzutage.
So, aber, jetzt machen wir mal weiter.
Genug gesidetracked.
Hast du Tipps, wie man sich neue Technologie aneignet?
Hast du nicht gestern schon gefragt?
Hab ich doch gestern schon was zugesagt.
Du kannst mit dem Hammer auf die HDD hauen, aber, guck dir mal.
Also, du kannst mit dem Hammer auf die Festplatte hauen,
dann ist die Festplatte höchstwahrscheinlich kaputt
und keiner kann sie mehr auslesen.
Und wenn du ordentlich genug draufgehauen hast,
dann kannst du die höchstwahrscheinlich auch mit sehr großem Auswand
nicht mehr ordentlich restoren.
Einzelne Bereiche vielleicht noch, aber zusammenhängende Sache eher nicht.
So, die Sache, die man sich fragen muss, ist,
warum soll ich mich drauf verlassen müssen,
dass ich die Festplatte am Ende ihrer Lebenszeit
ordnungsgemäß mit einem Hammer zerstöre,
wenn ich das Problem direkt lösen kann,
indem ich sie von Anfang an vollverschlüssele.
Wenn du eine Festplatte von Anfang an vollverschlüsselst,
dann musst du sie nicht zerstören,
du musst dir gar keine Gedanken darüber machen.
Okay, du nimmst sie, schmeißt sie in den Müll,
irgendein random Dude kann die rausfischen,
den Motor reparieren, anschließend kann er nichts damit anfangen.
Du kannst sie zusätzlich mit dem Hammer kaputt hauen,
aber du hast von Anfang an grundsätzlich ausgeschlossen,
dass irgendjemand was damit anfangen kann.
Das ist besser, als sie danach kaputt zu machen,
wo wahrscheinlich nur keiner was damit anfangen kann,
sondern es geht einfach nicht.
Das ist der gleiche Grund,
warum ich es zum Beispiel doof finde,
dass man so viele IoT-Geräte
eben mit nur einem WLAN-Passwort versorgen kann.
Also die meisten Access Points,
die unterstützen ein WLAN mit einem Passwort.
Fertig.
Daraus ist ja das Wort WLAN-Passwort sogar entstanden.
Das ist ja fast schon ein eigenes Wort.
Aber die allermeisten Access Points
unterstützen ein WLAN, also eine SSID,
mit einem Passwort.
Und jeder, der in dieses WLAN rein will,
braucht das gleiche Passwort.
Manche Sachen können noch ein zusätzliches Gäste-WLAN,
weil die auch schon gecheckt haben,
ey, es ist keine gute Idee,
wenn man vielleicht für das normale WLAN irgendwelchen Gästen,
die nur kurz da sind, das Passwort gibt.
Aber jedes IoT-Gerät, was ihr in dieses WLAN hängt,
also von der Waage bis zur Glühbirne,
bis zum Android-TV-Stick am Fernseher,
bis zum Fernseher selbst, bis zu eurem Smart-Trainer,
alles, was ins WLAN kommt.
Und auch ganz kleine Sachen wie Glühbirnen heutzutage,
die du per App an- und ausschalten kannst.
Jede kleinste Sache, müsst ihr euch klar sein,
dass das WLAN-Passwort, euer WLAN-Passwort,
das heißt, wenn ihr das Gerät wegschmeißt,
irgendjemand das Gerät nimmt und das WLAN-Passwort aus dem Storage ausliest,
was bei den meisten Geräten wahrscheinlich gar nicht so schwierig ist,
kann sich in euer WLAN einloggen.
Die Chance, dass das passiert, ist recht gering.
Wahrscheinlich werden sich die meisten Leute nicht für euren Müll und euer WLAN interessieren.
Aber die Frage ist doch, warum muss das überhaupt so sein?
Also sprich, es wäre erstens cool,
wenn mehr Geräte WPA Enterprise unterstützen würden.
Und was noch viel geiler wäre,
wenn einfach die meisten Access-Point-Hersteller endlich auch mal anfangen
und nicht nur die teureren,
endlich auch mal anfangen, mehrere Passwörter pro WLAN zu unterstützen.
Das geht ja.
Das ist ja nichts Neues.
Das funktioniert.
Das unterstützen die meisten Hersteller bloß nicht.
Und zweitens, mit den preisigeren Access-Point-Produkten
kannst du mehrere Passwörter für das WLAN vergeben.
Das geht so weit, dass du ein Passwort pro Gerät vergeben kannst.
Ich mache das bei mir im WLAN mittlerweile so,
jedes Gerät, was bei mir ins WLAN kommt, auch ins IoT-WLAN,
bekommt, ich habe zwar noch ein WLAN-Passwort,
ein allgemeingültiges,
aber wahrscheinlich schon heute Abend,
ist das Allotrix?
Jedes Gerät, was bei mir ins WLAN kommt,
bekommt ein eigenes WLAN-Passwort.
Kein eigenes WLAN, keine eigene SSID,
nein, ein eigenes WLAN-Passwort.
Und wenn ich das Gerät wegschmeiße,
dann wird das WLAN-Passwort einfach gelöscht
bzw. aus dem Access-Point entfernt.
Und selbst wenn jemand das WLAN-Passwort ausliest,
kann er sich damit nicht mehr authentifizieren.
Das sind so Dinge, wo ich mir denke,
warum unterstützen das nicht einfach mehr Geräte?
Das würde Sachen viel, viel sicherer machen.
Wir haben das Video immer noch nicht fertig geguckt.
Wir gucken jetzt endlich fertig.
... weil man die eigenen Mails nicht in den USA gespeichert haben möchte.
Microsoft hat sich inzwischen zu der CT-Recherche geäußert
und erklärt etwas schwammig,
dass die E-Mail-Daten an die eigenen Server gesendet werden,
um das Benutzererlebnis zu verbessern.
25.000 Dollar dafür, dass ich Brettian Rust revite.
So viel Geld können die mir gar nicht bezahlen.
... zwar immerhin verschlüsselt bei Microsoft gespeichert werden,
aber auch nur mit dem Basic-Auth-Verfahren,
das für IMAP eigentlich unüblich ist.
Hä? Was soll das für eine Antwort sein? Das ergibt keinen Sinn.
Die Frage war, hallo Microsoft,
warum synkt ihr ungefragt User-Credentials bei euch in die Cloud?
... Zugangsdaten zu IMAP-Anbietern,
deren Server Microsoft mit dem Basic-Auth-Verfahren kontaktiert,
speichern wir als Benutzer-Token in verschlüsselter Form in der Mailbox des Anwender.
What? Das ist keine Antwort auf die Frage, Microsoft.
Und ja, es mag technische Gründe dafür geben,
aber die Reaktionen vieler Leute zeigen, dass ihnen gar nicht klar ist,
dass Microsoft...
Die Frage ist doch gewesen, warum synkt ihr überhaupt Passwörter zu euch?
... Nutzerdaten überträgt und Mails auf die eigenen Cloud-Server überträgt.
Das ganze Statement haben wir euch unten in der Beschreibung verlinkt.
Wenn ihr euch jetzt denkt, aber es ist doch alles gelöst,
da gibt es doch dieses DE-Mail, hat das nicht alle Proble...
...
namens besonderes elektronisches anwalts postfach und bea besonderes elektronisches anwalts postfach
das ist ja der deutscheste name den ich für ein produkt in langer zeit gehört habe und auch im
gesundheitswesen gibt es einfach ein netz im netz mit der telematik infrastruktur können kliniken
ärzte und apotheken patienten akten oder rezepte die kriegen sie einfach nicht geschissen was es
aber leider nicht gibt ist eine möglichkeit für ganz normale leute an unternehmen und behörden
rechtssicher e-mail zu versenden und so wie das aussieht wird das leider auch noch eine ganze
weile dauern mein fazit also was genau eine e-mail und das protokoll da drum rum können
muss war schon vor 40 jahren recht niedrig angesetzt und klar hat das problem geführt
aber das war wahrscheinlich auch der grund warum das ganze so erfolgreich wurde denn
während sich computer und das internet immer wieder verändert haben ist die e-mail eine
konstante in dem ganzen prozedere geblieben und genau deswegen ist die e-mail auch nicht
sie ist zu einfach zugänglich und zu etabliert egal ob kurze nachricht an die kollegen oder
förmliche mail was guckte die sortings sorting labels von b wo war das noch mal hier sorting
labels bespe er hat alles klar ok wieder verändert haben ist die e-mail eine konstante in dem ganzen
prozedere geblieben und genau deswegen ist die e-mail auch nicht tot zu kriegen sie ist zu
einfach zugänglich und zu etabliert egal ob kurze nachricht an die kollegen oder förmliche mail an
ein unternehmen mit einer mail kann man halt fast alles an textkommunikation machen nur leider ist
mail eben auch unsicher und unzuverlässig weil keine sicherheitsmechanismen zwingend
vorgeschrieben sind e-mail ist das schlechteste nachrichtensystem dass es gibt und doch das
mit auch das mit verbreitet sichert ihr e-mails noch mit weiteren kryptografie verfahren ab benutzt
überhaupt noch mail oder nur noch irgendwelche messenger insgesamt ist weniger mail geworden
schreibt es gerne in die kommentare und natürlich gerne abonnieren also mail ist schon weniger
geworden bei mir auch aber beispielsweise ganzen sachen wenn mich irgendjemand anschreibt so nach
dem motto max wir wollen dass du world of tanks spielst oder sowas das kommt alles noch an die
e-mail adresse so das haben wir schon geguckt ok chat da müssen wir jetzt durch wir gucken uns von
den games dann den test aber nicht mich interessiert das game nicht ich will ich will ich will mich
damit eigentlich gar nicht auseinandersetzen das ist zu klein das c++ das erkennt man als
nicht mehr guck wenn man sind tatsächlich echt nicht einfach guck mal wenn man das hier
rauszoomt so ungefähr so großen twitter erkennt man nicht was am plus plus dahinter ist sind echt
eine kunst für sich kann man irgendwas machen um seine eigenen sicher zu machen helfen solche
sachen ich kenne mich mit ihm jetzt nicht gut aus du kannst auf jeden fall du kannst auf jeden
fall dein e-mail klein auf plaintext only stellen das macht es für dich sicherer also ich benutze
nur thunderbirds seit jahren ja und was verschlüsselung angeht ja da bin ich ein bisschen da
bin ich ein bisschen planlos ich habe hunger was was ist was ist das was das schon wieder
das eiders eiders und kommt logins aber sich ok chat wer errät was es bei mir heute zu essen
gibt ihr kommt im leben nicht drauf nudeln mit lachs falsch falsch nudeln mit bolognese richtig
es gibt ja zu zwei varianten wenn es kein wenn es kein lachs mit nudeln gibt gibst du den mit
bolognese lasst uns das schnell noch mal angucken macht ja mal gute videos und davon habe ich gar
nicht so viel mitgekriegt was sie da treiben ja und voll digital mit eurem digitalen ausweis die
eu bastelt gerade an einem digitalen wunderwert der id wallet eine art magischer geldbörse was
ist eigentlich mit dem mit ppga youtube bewertungen los also mein das liegt am
aber warum wenn ihr keine likes angezeigt die auch irgendwie eure identitäts- und gesundheitsdaten
sicherer als omas sparschwein verwahren soll das klingt alles zu schön um wahr zu sein oder ist
es auch die technologie könnte genutzt werden um jegliche kommunikation online abzufangen und
natürlich dann wo wir gerade beim thema waren vorhin oder von allen staaten der eu ohne dass
es wirklich kontrolle oder irgendwelche limits darüber gibt damit ist das ganze system auch
perfekt geeignet für die hast du durchgemacht ja ich bin seit gestern 20 uhr online eine
chatkontrolle diese peinlichen flirt versuche von gestern nacht mit manfred von der abteilung
für 16 zu teilen ist nicht gerade die art von dreier die wir uns wünschen aber manfred ist
hot as fuck da bock drauf haben das sieht man deutlich aber da kommen wir noch dazu die ganze
diskussion um die eid also die elektronische id ist wie immer eine geheime party zu der wir alle
nicht eingeladen waren alles findet natürlich hinter verschlossenen türen statt er kann ja
nicht sein dass er mit was abgeht letzte trottel der vom türsteher abgewiesen wurde und um das
ganze noch spannender zu machen diese ei das verordnung ist im eu trilog am 8 das ja fast
schon akte x musik im hintergrund november schon akzeptiert worden und das obwohl durch ein leak
von drinnen an und also die öffentlichkeit alles ans licht kam und auch der bekritisiert wurde
experten vom chaos computer club professoren aus der ganzen eu die linux foundation und sogar
mozilla und sogar google haben die eu gewarnt dass da ein ich zitiere security risk ahead ist
und das alles damit ich mir online mein neues auto anmelden kann kommen die gruppe wir kümmern
uns heute um diesen nebeneffekt der ei das reform den ihr mir mindestens zugeschickt habt und was
da eigentlich für ein wirbel drum existiert und warum okay die hauptbeschwerde des ganzen
öffentlichen briefs naja nichts weniger als ein trojanisches pferd dass es den ganzen
mitgliedstaaten eu ermöglichen würde mit sogenannten quacks unsere daten zu schnappen
quacks sind qualifizierte website authentifizierung unsere benahmung ist einfach zu geil für alles
man die karte kommen wir gleich dazu dieser ok heißt im endeffekt qualifizierte website
heißt im endeffekt man in der mitte legal so quasi jeder browser hersteller ist gezwungen
einem ja eu einem eu zu einer eu zu trasten dass sie im zweifelsfall alles mit schneiden können
oder sowas in der richtung also würde ich jetzt rein interpretieren an der hand des namens was
es wirklich jetzt weiß ich auch nicht website authentifizierung zertifikate kommen wir gleich
dazu dieser kleine artikel in dieser eidas verordnung finde ich nicht schlecht was macht
eine ente auf dem ruder das ist das muss ich mir merken also habe ich wahrscheinlich wieder
vergessen bis nächste woche aber den witz finde ich gut winkt alle browser und damit übrigens
auch mobile apps alle zertifikate zu akzeptieren die unterhalb dem aktuellen sicherheitsstandard
liegen könnten was ungefähr so sicher ist wie ein schloss das mit kaugummi zusammengehalten wird
oder wie die eff das ganze beschreibt es würde unseren sicherheitsstandard zwölf jahre in der
iran hat auch schon versucht eigene browser da sehen das sieht man mal da sieht man mal mit was
für tollen ländern wir uns da vergleichen müssen ist das das kenne ich das ist das skelett was das
ist das skelett was an der decke hängt die vergangenheit befördern großartig dazu schauen
wir uns aber zunächst mal an wie eigentlich dieser ganze website shit funktioniert was sind denn
eigentlich zertifikate und wieso kann der staat nicht eigentlich sowieso alles mitlesen wenn ich
auf pop-up nach german man fucks the whole internet es gab es da wirklich es gab es da wahrscheinlich
wirklich was ist was macht eigentlich axel voss aktuell axel voss twitter gibt es gibt was macht
er was macht der typ noch gerade da ist er da ist er hat ja sehr beliebt gemacht ok da ist
noch aktiv ach ja die guten alten zeiten das bräuchte mal ein update naja also das ganze
geht so nehmen wir an ich bin eine webseite und du lieber zuschauer willst mich sehen also eine
website besuchen beispielsweise meine academy du klopfst an und sagst ich will reden du willst
reden ja ich will reden ok hier ist mein zertifikat danke ich habe dein zertifikat erhalten hier ist
mein zertifikat danke ich habe dein zertifikat erhalten stt prozent b86 und 80 db 7 kuett
kj dollar 0 lf p7 kicknet 2k 4uj 1s unterstrich ntn das ist natürlich stark vereinfacht aber
im grunde tauschen wir nur die schlüssel aus die wirklich jeder sehen darf die öffentlichen schlüssel
und haben am ende so die möglichkeit zu verschlüsseln dass ok ok ich weiß ich weiß ich weiß was er
sagen wird es wirklich nur unser gesprächs gegenüber also wenn ich verschlüssele dass nur
du das entschlüsseln kannst und andersherum das nennt sich asymmetrische typographie und ist ein
bisschen wie magie das ist wirklich so ich verschlüssel also so dass nur noch du lesen
kannst und du machst dasselbe mit mir ich habe mal ich habe mal erst gemacht also also nicht
nicht komplett erst ich habe den den public also den key transfer höher also so wie das erst auch
macht mal von hand gemacht auf auf auf einem papier durchgespielt wie das funktioniert ich
habe ich weiß es nicht mehr ich weiß es nicht mehr also es ist schon ein paar jahre her aber zu
dem zeitpunkt hatte ich es zumindest verstanden und das war gar nicht so kompliziert da geht es
irgendwie darum eine seite denkt sich zwei primzahlen aus und nimmt irgendwie zwei primzahlen
überträgt dann quasi das was die zahlen multipliziert ergeben keine ahnung ich ich
weiß nicht mehr es ist auf jeden fall ganz nice wenn man zwar durchgespielt hat also
weil man versteht ja oftmals nicht wie es sein kann dass du privat also ich muss ich muss das
anders sagen symmetrische verschlüsselung versteht ja eigentlich jeder ja du denkst
dir ein passwort aus du verschlüsselst den text mit dem passwort überträgt den verschlüssel im
text das passwort muss irgendwie dem empfänger bekannt sein und dann entschlüsselt das wieder
du musst das passwort aber nicht über den gleichen weg übertragen wie die nachricht also du kannst
zum beispiel wenn du hier mit jemand zusammensitzt könnt ihr euch zusammen ein passwort ausmachen ja
face to face dann fährt er heim und ihr schickt dem ein verschlüsselnden brief und er kann das
entschlüsseln weil das passwort sich gemerkt hat so symmetrische verschlüsselung check checken die
meisten leute asynchrone verschlüsselung ist ein bisschen komplizierter weil man denkt sich so wie
kann es sein dass zwei seiten über einen öffentlichen kanal wie das internet miteinander verschlüsselt
reden können aber sie den schlüssel im vorfeld die sie dafür brauchen sie tauschen ja gar nicht
den schlüssel direkt aus wie wie geht das dass die quasi öffentlich miteinander reden und trotzdem
verschlüsseln sachen austauschen können ohne dass jemand der alles mit schneidet das lesen kann dass
das funds das funds ich habe ich habe mal erst mit mit durchgespielt und meistens läuft ja dann so
es wird erst mal also asynchron ein synchroner schlüssel ausgetauscht also sprich du du du
baust du baust quasi die die für die verbindung auf und dann tauscht tauscht zu den synchronen
schlüssel aus darüber über die verschlüssel verbindung weil synchrone verschlüsselung hat
einfach schneller ist also ja was das nicht wozu dir das nicht hilft ist festzustellen dass der
andere auch wirklich der ist für den du ihn hältst das ist wieder was anderes ja aber ich
muss mir das machen vielleicht machen wir das mal im stream wir machen einmal so einen rsa ich weiß
nicht ob es handshake heißt oder so können wir mal können wir mal in dem im textdokument machen
das ist gar nicht so kompliziert es ist schon ein paar jahre her wo ich das gemacht habe es ist
es ist recht recht easy wenn man sich einmal angeguckt hat aber ich weiß es aus dem kopf
auch nicht mehr so apropos komische stimme übrigens ich habe ein experiment gewagt und
das gesamte hörbuch zu dem roman 1984 cringe kommentare künstlicher intelligenz sprechen
lassen mit besserer stimme natürlich für 9 euro das hörbuch hat zehn stunden und ich verlinke
euch in der endcard gegen diese art der kommunikation gibt es einen relativ einfachen
angriff zumindest wenn man eben der staat ist denn unsere schlüssel die müssen wir ja um zu
kommunizieren über vodafone oder telekom oder irgendjemand anders drüber laufen lassen die
können wir ja nicht persönlich austauschen und während wir diese schlüssel austauschen können
die die ja einfach ersetzen und ihre einfügen und am ende kommunizieren wir immer so dass
eigentlich der staat beziehungsweise der provider immer alles mitlesen kann also passwörter
kreditkarten suchanfragen damit das nicht passiert gibt es vertrauenswürdige anbieter
von solchen zertifikaten die packen dann ihre unterschrift darunter dass eben dass da gerade
wirklich das zertifikat von port der bootstrap academy ist und denen vertrauen wir das heißt
die zertifikate von diesen anbietern die sind bei uns auf dem rechner und auf dem handy ja
außer man ist komodo lässt sich das gut zertifikat klauen installiert solche anbieter
sind also sagen wir mal unfassbar kritisch denn die sind technisch gesehen in der lage diese
ganzen zertifikate immer dann auszutauschen wenn sie eben gerade lust und laune haben wir alle
müssen also denen anbietern vertrauen damit das alles also nicht passiert haben die meistens
glücklicherweise glücklicherweise gibt es dafür letztendlich mittlerweile
kommunikationsweg sprich vodafone oder telekom geben solche sachen nicht raus und sie werden
extrem streng kontrolliert das ist eigentlich sowas wie gewaltenteilung im internet so und
gibt man nun diese macht zurück in staatliche hände dann ist das eine art freifahrtschein um
verschlüsselung für den staat einfach wann immer sie wollen aufzubrechen und damit natürlich auch
in der lage zu sein nachrichten zu lesen online profile über uns zu erstellen mit all den daten
die sie haben alle daten einfach nach belieben sollte das kommen sollte das kommen bin ich der
erste der einen firefox fork verwendet mit den zertifikaten wieder entfernt also mit dem mit dem
trust store wieder entfernt einzusammeln und ich glaube ich glaube auch nicht dass firefox
da mitmachen wird es sei denn es ist gesetzlich dazu gezwungen und selbst dann ist man die frage
ob man die dazu wie weit man die dazu zwingen kann es kam ja schon öfters mal vor dass browser
quasi gegen solche versuche vorgegangen sind und zertifikate pläcklistet haben sogar die für solche
zwecke benutzt werden sollten und damit eigene komische ki projekte durchzuführen zum beispiel
die liste ist eigentlich hier recht endlos und das alles wird mit diesen quarks gemacht quarks
sind eigentlich websites die am ende eben eines dieser speziellen eu zertifikate haben das sind
zertifikate wie immer nur eben herausgegeben von einem anbieter von der eu wichtig ist aber
websites sind nicht verpflichtet quarks zu werden es könnte also alles so bleiben wie es ist ob du
hier bist und nicht das problem kommt in anderen facetten quarks könnten eine art vertrauen
symbolisieren nur eine quark sollte besucht werden alles andere ist ungefiltert ungeprüft
und der ganze böse anarchische teil des internets in dem halt dann die eu nicht mitlesen kann noch
regel 34 praktiziert wird das kann websites natürlich unter druck setzen so ein zertifikat
zu bekommen und wenn die dann so ein zertifikat haben dann kann der staat wieder theoretisch
alles mitlesen und damit besteht natürlich lass mich raten die begründung ist die gleiche wie
immer morde aufklären kinder pornos aufklären terrorismus aufklären und sowas das sind immer
die gleichen sachen die da als als begründung kommen das quarks plötzlich doch und als nächstes
und als nächstes kommen dann die copyright leute und sagen doch ja das ist auch mal gucke
pflichten werden weil die eu regeln zum beispiel ausgeweitet werden gibt es eine regelung dann
wird die ja häufig einfach erweitert und auf dinge angepasst ein beispiel wäre hier die
chatkontrolle dabei geht es darum dass eine ki über unsere privaten chats drüber laufen soll
und da mal reinguckt ob da vielleicht illegale materialien drin werden und das umzusetzen wäre
mit quarks so unfassbar einfach man müsste einfach eine jede chat applikation in der eu
verpflichten eine quark zu werden fertig schon kann der staat alles mitlesen und staatlich prüfen
außerdem muss diese funktion quarks zu akzeptieren in jeden browser eingebaut werden das wurde so
beschlossen browser meint damit wie gesagt alle ich werde als erstes auf dem browser
und fork verwenden auf dem desktop und fork verwenden wo das nicht drin ist ja mobile
wird in der tat enorm schwierig weil da hast du weniger einfluss drauf was du verwendest
bleibt ihr im endeffekt ja nur noch android mit im kasten custom browser unter ios kannst
vergessen da ist alles safari und wenn die das einbauen ist es überall eingebaut es gibt ja
kein chrome und firefox für ios apps die mit dem internet kommunizieren nutzen nämlich
iphone zertifikate der große problempunkt dabei ist jeder browser muss diese quarks akzeptieren
auch wenn die einen sicherheitsstandard von 1995 nutzen kein browser darf bei einer quark
nein sagen damit kann man effektiv als quark die sicherheit seines nutzers einfach herabstufen auf
1995 alles in allem ist das also im besten fall eine dumme richtlinie die sicherheitsmaßnahmen
in browsers und systemen außer kraft setzt die es zu guten gründen gibt im schlechtesten fall
aber kann das ganze system von häckern von häckern genau von häckern oder auch starke
menschen gebraucht werden die es vielleicht nicht ganz so genau nehmen mit der demokratie es könnte
also problemlos erweitert werden und da tut sich die frage auf was zum geier sucht so eine verordnung
eigentlich in der eidas reform eidas bedeutet digitale ausweis hier geht es um moment ich
weiß gar nicht wofür es steht jetzt das hat nichts miteinander zu tun denn in der ankündigung
und den öffentlichen dokumenten war auch nie die rede von irgendwelchen website zertifikaten
sagen wir es gibt ein gewisses misstrauen warum mit so einer verordnung so immens intransparent
umgekehrt sogar noch dass die instanz die all diese verwaltung firefox für ios gibt es als
app aber unter der haube ist es trotzdem safari micro apple erlaubt keine andere browser engine
als safari unter ios macht also die zertifikate für quacks ausstellt das ist das sie nein nicht
die von der tv werbung auf der man urheberrechtlich problematische dinge zu haupt findet mit am ende
das europäische institut für telekommunikationsnormen kurz sie hat eine gewisse vergangenheit und
auch gegen den habe ich schon immer sehr problematischen sicherheitsstandards 2009
beispielsweise wollte man den sicherheitsstandard tls 1.3 den wir übrigens alle für verschlüsselung
mit websites müssen einfach absetzen für ets das wurde von experten damals zerlegt denn
was so ultra dämliche idee man wir haben hier was was millionenfach getestet verwendet wird
sich etabliert hat ersetzen wir durch irgendwas von uns wo keiner eine ahnung hat ob es richtig
funktioniert was eventuell übelst unsicher ist weil es doch keine praxis erfahrungen hatten
wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal irgendwie sich leute die ahnung damit haben angeguckt haben
das erinnert mich ein bisschen an den wettbewerb wo es um es ging damals also es hieß ja nicht
schon immer es ist ja der ist ja der standardname im endeffekt ja der advance encryption standard
allerdings was es nicht heißt ist also es ist nicht der algorithmus in dem sinn also für es
wurde ein algorithmus gesucht über einen wettbewerb am anfang und ursprünglich also
der jetzt unter es bekannt war ursprünglich der das ist das was der den wettbewerb gewonnen hat
vermutlich ja und die telekom hat bei diesem wettbewerb wissen auch gar nicht so viele die
telekom hat bei diesem wettbewerb mitgemacht damals mit einem algorithmus der sich magenta
nannte die sind nicht weit gekommen die sind nicht weit gekommen after the presentation of the
cypher at the first is conference several cryptographers immediately also es haben
also nachdem die den vorgestellt haben haben einige crypto experten sofort fehler also
anfälligkeiten gefunden in diesem algorithmus und seitdem war die halt wieder weg so den
not advance beyond the first round cryptographic weakness were discovered and it was found to be
one of the slower ciphers also das war das war nicht nur schlecht das war auch noch langsam also
telekom hat es wieder voll gerissen bei dem wettbewerb hier übrigens ich finde es eine mega
idee und das sollten eigentlich alle so machen dass es wenn so wenn so neuer wenn so neuer
standard gesucht wird dass man den wettbewerb macht wenn ich eine super sache fördert letztendlich
kreative ansätze kreative ideen wettbewerb und am ende kommt das beste dabei raus war das zu
zeiten vor der asymmetrischen verschlüsselung asymmetrische verschlüsselung und symmetrisch
weil du brauchst beides du brauchst beides ich meine auch weil der browser asymmetrisch verschlüsselt
verschlüsselt er nicht alles asymmetrisch zum beispiel der also in der regel wird das so
gemacht es wird asymmetrisch verschlüsselt und zwar ein schlüssel um synchron damit nachher zu
verschlüsseln weil asymmetrisch einfach langsamer ist also du brauchst quasi sagen wir so eine
asymmetrische verbindung auf asymmetrisch verschlüsselte verbindung auf darüber tauscht
du dann einen schlüssel aus und danach verschlüsselst du mit diesem schlüssel symmetrisch weil schneller
ist also im prinzip ist das beides brauchst beides telekom hat den cloud ausfall ist echt
jemand der magenta cloud verwendet da musste da musste da musste man in microsoft trainer
kecken über mich ich habe ihn einfach mal demonstrativ gefragt er hat erzählt microsoft
also sind diese fazit von ihnen war halt microsoft cloud beste beste sache aber man kann microsoft
cloud auch super toll mit anderen anbietern verwenden und beispielsweise services von
anderen anbietern gut integrieren manchmal auch also microsoft sachen exportieren zu anderen
anbietern und da habe ich den damals gefragt ob denn auch magenta cloud support wird da hat er
nur gekackt und hat gar nichts großartig drauf gesagt also wahrscheinlich wollte er mir sagen
er verwendet sowas denn ich komme weiter ets entfernt ein wichtiges sicherheitsfeature
ohne scheiß da würde ich lieber die lidl cloud verwenden die haben wenigstens gut die telekom
hat auch erfahrung wir müssen die telekom gar nicht mal schlechter machen als sie sind die
telekom hat teilweise jetzt mal jetzt mal hier real talk ja und keine werbung für die telekom
hat schon durchaus fähige leute ja das ist ab und zu die ein oder anderen felds gibt die telekom
hat schon hat schon wirklich schlau leute ich habe letztens zum beispiel mit zwei block chain
experten telefoniert von der telekom und gut experten war ein bisschen viel gesagt der eine
hat ahnung der andere war der teamleiter also im endeffekt eine hatte ahnung der andere war aus
marketing gründen dabei und die haben uns dann ein bisschen erzählt wie das wie das intern bei
der telekom so läuft wie die das wie die da ihre block chain infrastruktur betreiben das ist schon
ziemlich bleeding edge neues zeug was die machen und das kann auch nicht jeder ich muss sagen die
haben durchaus fähige leute leider sieht man halt immer nur die felds ja ist die magenta cloud
open telekom cloud kann sein früher hieß es magenta cloud doch nicht aber ich glaube auch
ist das das telekom zeug im standard von tls namens vorwärts das ist eigentlich gar nicht so
wichtig aber der fakt dass sie war doch die geschichte mit ich bin jetzt nicht mal ganz
sicher ob das das ist was ich was ich meine vorwärts sie ist doch die geschichte mit dass
wenn ich heute war das war das das wenn ich heute was mit schneide das ist dann auch wenn das war
was anderes dann dann weiß ich es nicht oder dass ich dann mit den sachen von morgen ich kriege es
nicht mehr richtig zusammen was das war keine ahnung das kennt ihr vielleicht sogar all das
ist eigentlich gar nicht so wichtig aber der fakt dass ein bedeutendes feature einfach entfernt wurde
dass keinerlei nachteile bietet sondern sogar noch gegen quantencomputer schon heute für schutz
sorgt das ist ein gewisser beigeschmack da hatte ich übrigens auch schon ein video dazu gemacht
und auch im standard für polizei und militärradius der natürlich auch verschlüsselt sein sollte wurde
buchstäblich eine hintertür gefunden der standard wurde 1995 entwickelt und befindet sich in allen
möglichen geräten von motorola über airbus allerdings wurde dieser standard nie der
öffentlichkeit zugänglich gemacht und so wurde erst diesen sommer also fast 30 jahre später eine
sicherheitslücke entdeckt wäre das ganze öffentlich gewesen dann hätten da mehrere leute drüber gucken
können und das hätte wahrscheinlich nicht so lange gedauert da gibt es ja zig beispiele für
eines meiner lieblings security sachen wo ich wo ich in den letzten jahren über immer mal wieder
ein bisschen verfolgt hat ist die ganze management sachen die bei intel mainboards und intel
enterprise sachen eingebaut sind da gibt es doch diese intel management engine geschichten und
dieses ding hatte schon immer regelmäßig irgendwelche sicherheitslücken aber intel sagt
er halt nichts zu du hast keine ahnung wie es funktioniert keine ahnung was es macht es
kommen bloß regelmäßig sicherheitslücken raus wo leute wieder geschafft haben diese komische
intel management engine zu exploiten und auch der verschlüsselungsalgorithmus aus den 1990ern
für mobile telefone wurde vom etsy entwickelt und nicht veröffentlicht 2021 also in diesem fall über
30 jahre später haben forscher der ruhr universität bochum eine sicherheitslücke
gefunden die ich zitiere sehr unwahrscheinlich durch einen unfall erstellt also war sich eingebaut
und übrigens es gibt eine wortwörtliche arbeitsgruppe des etsy die einen standard
entwickelt der sich mit rechtmäßiger überwachung und aufbewahrung von daten für strafverfolgen
beschäftigt also zusammengefasst browser werden zu schwächeren sicherheitsstandards gezwungen von
einer institution die eine gewisse geschichte mit staatlicher überwachung hat und das möglichst
unauffällig in einer verordnung wo es eigentlich um unseren digitalen ausweis gehen sollte ist
klar vermutlich möchte man einfach mit anderen staaten gleichziehen die dieses absolut demokratische
werkzeug schon längst nutzen iran zum beispiel praktiziert das ganze aktiv oder china oder
kasachstan aber lasst uns noch einen ganz kurzen blick auf den eigentlichen ausweis werfen denn
auch dabei gibt es einiges an kritik in dem artikel 6 der reform aktuell sieht der verordnungsentwurf
vor dass relying parties aus der id wallet daten verknüpfen oder verfolgen können sprich nutze ich
da fragt man sich halt welche parties das dann sind die academy und eine krankenkasse und melde
mich dort jeweils an dann können die daten von diesen relying parties zusammengeführt werden und
zu diesen relying parties zählen eben auch regierung ach ja dadurch wird profiling natürlich
ziemlich gut möglich teilt sogar wenn die inhaber sprich ich dem ganzen über ihren ausweis nicht mal
zugestimmt haben es steht zwar viel drin bezüglich strengen schutz vor tracking und profiling aber
leider ist dieser schutz laut dieser verordnung halt einfach keine pflicht sondern er ist komplett
optional und da die id wallet einfach identitätsdaten finanzdaten und sogar gesundheitsdaten enthalten
sollen für millionen bürger wäre das vielleicht schon ganz sinnvoll wenn es nicht optional ist
wird gesammelt was möglich ist technisch und rechtlich das finde ich auch der serverseite
gekauft der eid muss nicht quell offen sein das ist auch immer so ein ding dass das nicht nur
so geheim hinter den bühnen irgendwie immer alles ausge ausgeheckt wird aber dass du noch nicht mal
wenn du mehr oder weniger quasi gezwungen wirst den scheiß zu verwenden noch nicht mal in der
lage bis zu gucken okay ist was was was was läuft da eigentlich so könnte man zum beispiel auch
feststellen okay der scheiß ist richtig stümperhaft und schlecht implementiert hat sicherheitslücken
erst fahrrad ist war deswegen wollen sie es wahrscheinlich nicht weil eins muss man ja mal
festhalten viele leute werfen dann immer eins und nach dem motto ja aber sowas sicherheitskritisch
es kann doch nicht quell offen sein und das sage ich als antwort doch gerade was sicherheitskritisch
muss quell offen sein der witz ist ja sicherheit bedeutet ja in dem fall du musst wissen können oder
du darfst wissen wie etwas funktioniert bis ins detail aber dieses wissen alleine darf dir trotzdem
nicht helfen das auszuhebeln das ist ja gerade der sinn davon machen wir machen wir mal ein ganz ganz
einfaches beispiel ja also ich ich generiere eine random zahl oder ich ich generiere eine zahl und
ich teile die mit modulo und nehme den rest also ich mache ich mache keine ahnung ich gerne mir
generieren wir eine zahl und sagen mal sieben oder oder zehn oder so und sagt dann mod 3 und
den rest und ich verschicke ich verschicke nur den rest da könnte man jetzt sagen okay
ich kann das mitlesen und ich weiß wieder wieder algorithmus funktioniert jetzt weiß ich was du
ursprünglich für eine zahl generiert hast weiß ich nicht ich weiß dass irgendjemand eine zahl
generiert hat und davon den rest genommen hat aber ich habe keine ahnung was er wirklich gemacht hat
obwohl ich weiß wie der algorithmus funktioniert und ich kann plaintext lesen was er übertragen hat
jetzt vielleicht schlechtes beispiel aber ich glaube ihr wisst was ich meine also du in dem
fall darfst du wissen wie das funktioniert und du darfst auch alle daten mitlesen und du weißt
trotzdem nicht die geheime zahl im endeffekt meine es ist relativ easy auszuprobieren dann bei kleinen
zahlen und so muss das sein du musst wissen wie es funktioniert guckt guckt euch den linux guckt
euch linux an ich will nicht sagen dass jeder bei linux durchblickt es gibt wahrscheinlich nur ein
paar handvoll leute auf der welt die da wirklich durchblicken aber trotzdem dass der linux kernel
an sich und alle standard tools offen sind gibt es doch verhältnismäßig wenig sicherheitslücken
guckt euch mal an sudo zum beispiel und sudo hat eine historie mit sicherheitslücken da gab es
immer mal wieder welche aber sogar sudo also quasi ein kommando wo ich mit meinem user als
admin mich einloggen kann also wer es nicht kennt ich zeige es euch ganz einfach so hier bin ich
mein user so ich bin max max darf aber beispielsweise an systemdatei nichts machen also sage ich sudo
minus i dann muss ich ein passwort eingeben und dann bin ich root, root ist quasi administrator unter linux
und trotzdem dass diese tools alle open source sind kann nicht jeder daher gelaufene hinz und
kunst einfach root werden auf meinem server weil das tool soweit sicher ist dass es eben das macht
was es soll und obwohl du weißt wie es programmiert wurde trotzdem nicht einfach jetzt ausnutzen
kannst also das ist sicher dadurch unter anderem weil es so viele leute benutzen so viele leute
sich den source code angucken können ich habe absichtlich sudo genommen weil bei sudo sieht man
dass selbstverständlich auch open source software nicht davor sicher ist sicherheitslücken zu haben
es gab nämlich erst vor einst zwei jahren diese diese geschichte hiermit war dann mal so ok ich
bin wieder da ja also ich habe absichtlich sudo genommen weil bei sudo gab es letztens eine
größere sicherheitslücke da konntest du relativ einfach gut werden aber es ist ein gutes beispiel
für gewesen dass man sieht ok und selbst wenn man weiß wie die sachen funktionieren darf man nichts
das trotzdem umgehen können damit was möglich ist technisch und rechtlich experten sehen auch
im konzept ausweis im internet insgesamt ein problem das ist ein leichtes zu sagen websites
für erwachsene spieler ab 18 da müssen wir uns ausweisen das wäre natürlich erstmal einfach
nicht angenehm aber vielleicht noch verständlich aber wo hören wir auf was wenn youtube auf
einmal sich entscheidet bots eindämmen zu wollen und deshalb einfach basierend auf der id menschen
von der plattform aussperrt wenn sie ein schlechtes kommentar zum beispiel geschrieben haben dazu
brauchen sie dann auch eine id was wenn online spiele fast wie in china dann wir wollen uns nicht
wurde überall und in korea ist es nicht sogar in südkorea so also südkorea nicht nordkorea
südkorea dass wenn du dich bei einem mmo anmeldest du das nur mit ausweis id darfst
und du im zweifelsfall wenn du cheats gebannt wirst mit ausweis id und sowas schutz von
minderjährigen rumschlagen also ausweis her unser games ab 18 nicht nur wird es immer normaler es
würde auch immer häufiger werden und immer mehr websites hätten unsere identität die natürlich
auch verknüpft werden kann denn über die meisten website ist einfach nicht brauchen haben wir noch
nicht mal gesprochen ausweisdaten finanzdaten und gesundheitsdaten auf einer einzigen plattform für
millionenbürger und dann sogar noch die möglichkeit einfach eine blanco überwachung zu machen selbst
wenn wir maximales vertrauen in unseren staat haben das sind daten mit denen man richtig viel
unfug machen kann ich überlasse das einfach mal eurer kreativität die vfn sich kommt genau richtig
zu dem video gerade danke für die zahl mit sowas anstellen könnte jeder bösartige hacker denkt
sich bei solchen daten und ganz ehrlich deutschland ist ein technisches entwicklungsland
uns anzumassen dass wir es damit staatlichen hackern aus ist das nicht der typ der immer
zigarren testet von dem habe ich auch schon paar videos geguckt die aufnehmen könnten ich rauche
nicht einfach lächerliche hybris ich finde die videos mega entspannend ich denn dann von
dem auch schon paar videos geguckt irgendwelche zigarren tests oft was verdient also jetzt gucken
wir das nächste mal check ich habe hunger ich esse jetzt was nudeln mit mit tomatensauce vielleicht
sehen wir uns heute abend wieder zu einer weiteren runde blazingly fast written in rust muss ich mal
gucken wie wie ich das nenne ok moment chat ich erkenne gar nicht was was man da sieht was sieht
man da man sieht c++ ach auf einem keck das ist auch noch nicht so das wie gesagt twitch twitch
emotes sind echt sind echt so ein ding für sich also ich bin der sache auf jeden fall positiv
aufgeschlossen wenn wir ein schönes c++ keck emote finden dann nehmen wir das alles klar wir sehen uns